werden und dass wir mit erneuerbaren
Energien wie Wind und Sonne die uns
keine Rechnung schicken eben dann
deutlich auch die Energiekosten runter
senken wir haben ja momentan eine Fossil
getriebene Inflation war einig vor allen
Dingen an den flotionen die dich die
hohen Gaspreise kommt und ich
Spekulation die Russland noch zusätzlich
anheizt das ist ein fossiles Problem und
das müssen wir überwinden auch wegen der
Klimakrise und deswegen haben wir auch
ganz zentral nicht nur um Einzelplan 09
sondern auch im großen
klimotransformationsfonds wurden
Großteil der Gelder auch vom Wirtschaft
und Klima Minister Habeck bewirtschaftet
werden große Investitionen vor im
Bereich des grünen Wasserstoffs im
Bereich der Gebäudesanierung im Bereich
des klimaneutral Umbaus der Industrie
wir haben rekordinvestitionen in diesem
Haushalt insbesondere für Klimaschutz
und Transformation und so wollen wir uns
unabhängig machen auch von fossilen
Energien aber auch von Autokraten nicht
nur aus Russland auch überall auf der
Welt vor allem jetzt auf den letzten
Punkt haben wir gleich noch mal weil da
ist ja ein Zwischenschritten nötig
irgendwie überleben fossile
Energieträger das ist ja ganz Spann
vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen über
LNG und die Kosten für die Terminals
Herr lenkert wie sehr sind sie überzeugt
von dem Konzept dass der Kindler hier
gerade erläutern hat es ist nicht
ausreichend es ist natürlich richtig die
erneuerbaren Energien auszubauen die Gas
und strompreisbremsen aus unserer Sicht
viel zu hoch aber wenn wir nicht das
gesamte
Strommarktes ein komplett ändern wird
man sich in den Griff kriegen also ein
einfaches Beispiel nächstes Jahr werden
13 Milliarden Euro allein dafür benötigt
und den Strom handelt sicherzustellen
zwischen Nord und Süddeutschland die
Europäische Union hat vorgeschlagen
Deutschland in zwei stromhandelszonen zu
trennen dann könnten wir uns diese 13
Milliarden sparen die werden die
vermissten die VerbraucherInnen
Verbraucher zahlen sie werden jetzt aus
dem Resten des erneuerbaren Energien
Fonds genommen für nächstes Jahr über
nächstes Jahr funktioniert nicht oder
System bei Strompreisen es ist doch
Irrsinn wenn ein Unternehmen eine
erzeugungstechnologie die zehn Cent
braucht für die Kilowattstunde
Produktion mit gewinnen dann vielleicht
18 im Moment sogar 25 30 Cent bekommt
wobei das stromagte sein so ist
das muss kann man ändern das muss man
ändern das wäre dringend nötig das zu
unternehmen weil wenn das nicht geändert
wird so viel Strompreis bremsen kann
kein Bundeshaushalt finanzieren die dann
notwendig werden um bezahlbare
Energiekosten sicherzustellen
glaube ich mit einem Satz noch mal sagen
auch wenn es viele inzwischen natürlich
wissen ist irgendwie der das Prinzip das
im Grunde das teuerste der am teuersten
hergestellte Strom den Preis für alle
anderen auch bestimmt was ist denn ihr
konzeptsystem muss sofort weg
beziehungsweise massiv überarbeitet ist
eine Höchstgrenze gibt für jede
kraftwerksorte zum Einspeisen das zweite
ist wir brauchen einheitliche
Netzentgelt in der Bundesrepublik die
Ausgleich über alle Ebenen weil wir
haben Unterschiede zwischen 15 sind
zwischen den höchsten und den
niedrigsten Netzentgelt für
endverbrauchen Verbraucher das ist nicht
fair und gerade dort wo erneuerbare
Energien besonders stark ausgebaut sind
ist der Strompreis am höchsten
marktwirtschaftlich irre in Bayern wo es
kaum Strom gibt es der Strompreis am
niedrigsten in Schleswig-Holstein
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern ist am höchsten
der Endpreis für Strom das muss geändert
werden das wollen wir ändern und
natürlich wollen wir auch noch insgesamt
ich sage es ganz deutlich die
adressbarkeit des Staates der
Gesellschaft durch das privat-eigentum
an Energieinfrastruktur wie wir es eben
bei Gasproben gesehen haben muss
überwunden werden wir müssen das
vergesellschaften jetzt haben wir
ziemlich viele Punkte
ja das Problem
gerne anfangen wir können mit dem
Stromer die sein anfangen das Problem
ist sie müssen jetzt sehr sehr
kurzfristig unsere Volkswirtschaft unser
Energie System stabilisieren das
übrigens auch kein deutsches Energie
System ist sondern wir haben eine
europäischen Strommarkt wir haben eine
europäisches
Gasmarkt das heißt wir müssen auch
gucken was wir kurzfristig hinbekommen
und alle Experten experten sagen wir
müssen dann Strom macht Design ran ja
aber das geht nicht innerhalb von zwei
Monaten dafür brauchen wir
wahrscheinlich mehrere Jahre weil es so
komplex ist weil es euphorisch betrifft
weil es viele andere Länder auch in
Europa mit beeinträchtigen und
beeinbeziehen muss deswegen wollen wir
daran aber man kann das so kurzfristig
nicht machen so muss jetzt kurzfristig
gucken wie man die Preise unterbringt
dafür haben die Strom und gaspreisbremse
eingeführt zu Gastraum kann ich nur
sagen die Linke hat ja auch lange
einfach auch an Nordstemmen eins und
Nord Stream 2 festgehalten und Teile der
Linken vor dann die immer noch dass wir
die Pipeline aus Russland wieder
benutzen so wie Klaus Ernst also von
daher kann ich die Kritik nicht ganz
nachvollziehen einfach einen kleinen
Exkurs zu Nord Stream 1 aber wirklich
ein kleines
Diskurs wir haben eindeutige
parteibbeschluss und wir sind aber eine
pluralistische Partei das heißt bei uns
darf jeder auch seine eigene Meinung
äußern die Fraktion ist eindeutig die
Partei steht eindeutig Nord Stream 2 ist
technisch überflüssig gewesen jetzt ist
es technisch nicht mehr einsetzbar es
gäbe hätte genügend Kleidung gegeben und
im übrigen mit einer besseren
Diversifizierung der Belieferung wenn
man zum Beispiel auch den Deckel für die
Einspeisung von biometern endlich
aufheben würde könnten wir die
Eigenversorgung auch erhöhen das heißt
es gäbe genügend Möglichkeiten die
Gasversorgung sicherzustellen auch ohne
diese Leitung deswegen haben wir auch
diese Beschlüsse und das einige
natürlich immer laut schreien das ist
bei jeder Partei so die Meinung ist
besonders laut aber okay
ein anderes Stichwort das Herr Längert
eben genannt hat war er pressbarkeit
durch
beispielsweise auch Länder
die sagen wir mal zumindest zweifelhafte
Regierungssysteme haben das bahnt sich
ja jetzt auch wieder rund um das Thema
LNG dann noch mal an wie stehen Sie dazu
also wir haben seit 2014 davon gewarnt
192 in Betrieb zu nehmen wir hatten
leider recht weil wir uns erpressbar
gemacht haben vom russischen Diktator
wir haben aber auch schon lange gewarnt
dass wir uns von Öl von Gas und von
Kohle abhängig machen wo vielfach die
Ressourcen in diktatorischen oder
autokratischen Regime liegen deswegen
haben die Grünen lange für die
Energiewende gekämpft sie wurde lange
blockiert insbesondere von der CDU
deswegen machen wir es mit
höchstschritten daran dass zu beenden
wir haben das größte Paket von
erneuerbaren Energien seit 20 Jahren vor
der Sommerpause durch den Bundestag
gebracht dass er das ohne die Grünen
dieser Regierung nicht gegeben und wir
werden vor allem auch einen starken
Schwerpunkt Energieeffizienz setzen sehr
ambitionierten Gesetz für
Energieeffizienz und wir werden bei den
Strom und gaspreisbremse auch darauf
achten dass vor allen Dingen auch viel
Gas und Strom auch einsparen weil wir
müssen eine gefährliche gasmangelage in
diesem Winter verhindern das können wir
bei höchstwahrscheinlich aber wir müssen
immer runterkommen mit der Energie vor
allem nicht Effizienz zu LNG machen wir
gleich
meine Vorlage deswegen muss ich mich
entschuldigen muss es dann ein bisschen
nach hinten verschieben ich habe das
irgendwie etwas leichtfertig gerade nach
vorne geschoben aber was sie gerade vom
Thema Einsparungen reden was ist der
Stand der Dinge können Sie das sagen
ich war ja immer von 20% die Rede sowohl
Haushalt ist einsparen sollten private
als auch Unternehmen ich weiß gar nicht
habe ich jetzt schon eine ganze Weile
nichts mehr gehört ob Sie ob das
tatsächlich funktioniert die Woche
geredet so wir sind ungefähr bei
Unternehmen jetzt bei Einsparung war ca
25% Gas bei privaten Haushalt sehen wir
sogar jetzt zum stand jetzt ca 40 %
Einsparung bei Gas also sehr große
Erfolge die wir jetzt haben wir müssen
eben gucken wie weit das eben auch
diesen Winter nach durchträgt und wie
das langfristige Effekte auch ist sind
weil ja auch Glas wir können nicht auf
Dauer fossile Preise funktionieren also
war das zusammen so funktionieren wir
auch fossile Preise wir brauchen dafür
auch execzenarien weil wir nicht mehr
billiges russisches Gas auf Dauer haben
werden und das ist auch sinnvoll ist
wegen der Klimakrise müssen wir gucken
dass wir mehr Energie einsparen
effizienter nutzen Herr Lenkrad direkt
dazu wenn Sie mögen direkt dazu
sicherlich müssen wir aus dem fossilen
raus aber parallel und eben auch um das
finanzieren zu können und eben auch
bessere entlastungspakete finanzieren zu
können ist das zwingend erforderlich
dass man die extra Gewinne der Konzerne
ordentlich besteuert eine
übergewinnsteuer ist unerlässlich und
die darf sich nicht mehr auf den
Energiesektor beschränken ein einfaches
Beispiel Kali und Salz hat sein Umsatz
im Geschäft ja mit 20% weniger
kalkuliert aber ein fünfachen gewinnen
das heißt also Preissteigerung auf
ganzer Front die durchgesetzt werden
können weil Mangel da ist und diese
übergewinne die nicht mit Investition zu
tun haben nicht mit ich sag mal realer
Arbeit die müssen kassiert werden und
dann haben wir auch genügend mit um eine
bessere gaspreisbremse um ein besserer
Strompreis Bremse zu bezahlen das ist ja
geplant und das ist auch haben der
Koalition
dass man sich da so zumindest sagen dass
einige Kommentatoren doch
vergleichsweise genügsam zeigt wenn man
versucht irgendwie mal gerade eine
Milliarde Euro dazu erheben auf diesem
Weg na wir werden ja übergewinnen gerade
im energie-sektor abschöpfen das haben
wir jetzt auch noch mal beschlossen im
Bereich von Kohle Atom auch erneuerbaren
Energien wo einfach hohe Gewinne
angefallen sind und einfach nicht
gerechtfertigt sind durch Investitionen
das werden wir machen strompreisbremse
zu finanzieren wir haben jetzt auch noch
mal deutlich gemacht dass wir auch im
Bereich der Ölunternehmen und
mineralwirtschaft das abschöpfen wollen
dass hätten als wir das zuerst gefordert
haben als Grüne haben viele gesagt das
werdet ihr die durchsetzen jetzt haben
wir davon wichtigen Schritt erzielt wir
diskutieren in der Koalition noch über
genau Ausgestaltung aber sind wichtiger
Schritt für mehr Gerechtigkeit in dieser
Krise jetzt kommen wir zum Thema LG
damit wir das noch hinkriegen weil wir
so dramatisch viel Zeit jetzt auch nicht
mehr haben und weil ich vorhin auch
schon mal angesprochen habe sie können
ihre kurze Bemerkung noch machen die
ihnen auf der Zunge liegt die meisten
übergewinde sind angefallen zwischen
November übrigens schon vor dem Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine bis August
und sie soll erst ab September
eingeführt werden also insofern
verzichtet die Regierung leider auf
einen Großteil möglicher Einnahmen
außerdem ist das bemessen die
messungsgrundlage viel zu klein aber das
ja im Prinzip aber
diese ganzen Fragen diskutieren in der
Koalition bei der nächsten Gelegenheit
die Kosten für Terminals für LNG können
wir diese Woche in dieser Woche hören
haben sich verdoppelt von ursprünglich
mal um die drei Milliarden Euro jetzt
auf sechseinhalb was ist denn das schief
gelaufen einerseits werden jetzt mehr
Terminals ähm für für mobile LNG Schiffe
es geht hier am fslus also mobile LED
Schiffe werden mehr Terminals
bereitgestellt von der Bundesregierung
oder aber vorher schon ausgegangen von
designal nein das ist eine Erhöhung
gewesen wir sind jetzt bei sechs
Schiffen das noch mal eine Erhöhung die
Laufzeit werden zum Teil länger und
trotzdem ist es so dass die
Weltmarktpreise explodieren und wir aber
im Haus des Autos gesagt haben wir
brauchen dafür einen Gesamtkonzept wir
haben wir in vielen Bereich erreichen
auch hier
Gelder zum Teil gesperrt und wir haben
eingefordert dass eben die
Bundesregierung jetzt ein Gesamtkonzept
für die LNG Förderung von festen
Terminals von mobilen Terminals
anschaffen muss weil wir mehr
Transparenz über Kosten und über die
Kapazitäten und auch die Vereinbarkeit
mit den Klimaschutzgesetz brauchen ich
habe gelesen die Betriebskosten seinen
Schuld und nötige Infrastrukturmaßnahmen
an die man am Anfang nicht gedacht hat
und was auch immer das im Detail heißt
und dadurch sind die Kosten für haben
sich verdoppelt es gibt glaube es gibt
verschiedene Effekte so im Kern ist es
natürlich so dass wir bis Anfang Februar
überhaupt gar nicht über LNG nachgedacht
haben in Deutschland jetzt kurzfristig
um satteln müssen und gleichzeitig eben
auch die firmene sehr günstigen Lage für
sie sind weil eben ganz viele Länder der
Welt jetzt zusätzlich Energie beschaffen
auch das nachvollziehen das Gas auch da
müssen wir rauskommen auch das kann
kurzfristig und die Gasversorgung sicher
wir müssen aufpassen das wäre doch da
mittelfristig keine Fossil neuen
Abhängigkeit schaffen deswegen haben wir
das auch gesagt wir brauchen mehr
Transparenz über die Kosten über die Kap
Aktivitäten und über die Risiken dieser
Projekte und haben dann klaren Bericht
der Bundesregierung angefordert diese
neuen Abhängigkeiten ist genau das was
sie befürchten oder wie befürchten wir
uns vor allen Dingen befürchten wir das
eben eine fossile Infrastruktur auf
Jahrzehnte festgelegt wird das
Lieferverträge eben über 20 Jahre
abgeschlossen werden und wenn man
natürlich ein lng-termine Fest baut ist
ich meine das nicht die flexible dann
muss natürlich über Jahre betrieben
werden damit das sich rechnet und diese
Behauptung man könnte die Infrastruktur
weiterverwenden die stimmt einfach nicht
okay die Hafenanlage kann man weiter
verwenden die Anlegestelle den Landstrom
kann weiter verwenden eventuell kann man
noch die Leitung umrüsten auf
Wasserstoff aber alles was Pumpen ist
entspannungsanlagen die ganzen
technische Equipment ist nicht nutzbar
für andere Sachen es wäre klüger die
festen Bauten sofort in Wasserstoff oder
Ammoniak zu investieren bei ansonsten
sind die festen energy Terminals eine
tote Investition die uns eigentlich
leisten können
das ist ja doch ein relativ harsches
Urteil erstens wird das mit geplant also
müssen genau gucken bei Ammoniak und bei
grünen Wasserstoff dass das mitgeplant
wird gerade bei den Festen Terminals die
Frage ist aber wie viel brauchen wir
eigentlich auch davon weil wir natürlich
auch jetzt sehr viele mobile Schiffe
auch haben und noch mal kurzfristig sind
wir unabhängig vom russischen Gas
deswegen mussten wir auch andere Quellen
kurzfristig für die Gasversorgung uns
holen aber am Ende darf es nicht dazu
führen damit ich mir den Lenkrad einig
dass sie im fossile Abhängigkeiten
kommen dass wir am Ende zu viel Geld
bezahlen und dass wir den wichtigen
Umbau auf grünen Wasserstoff auf Amazon
Jack oder von erneuerbare Energien auf
Einsparung Effizienz von Energie dass
wir das durch zu hohe Kosten und zu viel
Kapazität kaputt machen da werden wir
sehr genau achten im Parlament in dem
Haus aus Autos ganz kurz zum Abschluss
weil wir hier über Energiepreise geredet
haben und auch die Versuche die zu
decken und für die Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher einigermaßen erträglich zu
halten was ist ihre Prognose der Lenkrad
für die Entwicklung der Energiepreise in
den nächsten drei vier fünf Monaten
hängt davon ab ob man die Spekulation
bekämpft wenn man sie nicht bekämpft
werden sie auf dem hohen Niveau bleiben
auf dem sie jetzt sind dann reichen die
Hilfspakete definitiv nicht okay dann
braucht man eine Unterstützung auch um
die höheren Preise im gesamten
Lebensmittel Einzelhandel überall
abfangen zu können durch die Inflation
eben auch durch Energiepreise verursacht
und da wäre es unerlässlich dass man für
die kleinen mittleren Einkommen eine
monatliche Pauschalzahlung hinzunimmt
aus unserer Sicht von 75 € je Haushalte
im Monat und 50 € je Person im Haushalt
die Herzen für die Menschen entlassen
Kindergeld mit einem höheren Wohngeld
höheren ag2 Bezügen wir haben Rentnerin
Studierende Azubis unterstützt das 49
Euro eingeführt also die Bundesregierung
macht sehr viel und diese Koalition für
Unterstützung von kleinen mittleren
Einkommen wir müssen leider Schluss
machen weil es geht nämlich gleich
drinnen los und ich glaube nicht dass
sie zu spät kommen wollen sagen Sie mir
noch in einem Satz ihre Prognose für die
Energiepreise in kurzen wenn es geht
kurzen sehen wir dass die Preise sinken
und ich gehe davon aus dass wir
hinbekommen werden dass sie auch weiter
sinken werden Herr
lenkert Herr Kindler vielen Dank dass
Sie heute morgen hier gewesen sind
vielen Dank für das lebendige und aber
trotzdem konstruktive Gespräch und ich
gebe ganz fix rein in das plenumländer
ist die Bundestagspräsidentin schon
angekommen
vor Eintritt in die Tagesordnung
gratuliere ich heute dem Kollegen Dr
Johannes Fechtner zu seinen 50
Geburtstag
im Namen des ganzen Hauses alles Gute
der Entwurf eines Jahressteuergesetzes
2022 auf Drucksache
3.879
sowie die der zugehörige Stellungnahme
des Bundesrates und die Gegenäußerung
der Bundesregierung auf Drucksache
4.229 sollen nachträglich dem
Wirtschaftsausschuss zur mitberatung
überwiesen werden ich sehe keinen
Widerspruch dazu
dann sind die genannten Drucksachen an
den Wirtschaftsausschuss überwiesen
weiter beantragen die koalitionsfraktion
die Tagesordnung um folgenden Punkt zu
erweitern der gleich zu Beginn der
Tagesordnung aufgerufen werden soll
Beschlussempfehlung des
Vermittlungsausschusses zu dem 12 Gesetz
zur Änderung des zweiten Buches
Sozialgesetzbuch und anderer Gesetze
Einführung eines Bürgergeldes das
sogenannte bürgergeldgesetz auf
Drucksache 4600
ich habe gehört dass dazu das Wort
gewünscht wird zur Geschäftsordnung und
zuerst hat das Wort für die SPD-Fraktion
Katja Mast
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen durch das
Ergebnis des Vermittlungsausschusses vom
Mittwoch der eine Einigung zwischen Bund
und Ländern erzielte können wir heute
den Weg frei machen für das Bürgergeld
es geht um die Größe sozialstaatsreform
seit Jahrzehnten damit das Bürgergeld
zum ersten Januar ausgezahlt werden kann
müssen heute Bundestag und Bundesrat
zustimmen sonst klappt das nicht und
gerade in diesen schwierigen Zeiten
wissen viele Menschen
darunter viele alleinerziehende Mütter
nicht wie sie über die Runden kommen
sollen umso wichtiger ist dass sie
Sicherheit haben
dass ab 1 Januar der Regelsatz um 53
Euro steigt
ja es ist haushaltswoche und ja hier
findet Gesetzgebung nur in begründeten
Ausnahmefällen statt aber die Nord der
Betroffenen ist groß und das allein ist
Grund für die Eilbedürftigkeit
Planungssicherheit ist das Gebot der
Stunde das Bürgergeld ist ein
Systemwechsel hin zur Vermittlung in
dauerhafte
Beschäftigung statt kurzfristiger
Hilfsjobs hinzu mehr Qualifizierung und
das muss auch in den Jobcentern auf den
Weg gebracht werden auch dazu brauchen
wir jetzt hier und heute rechts und
Planungssicherheit für die Jobcenter
und wir wollen die Jobcenter an einigen
Stellen von unnötiger Bürokratie
entlasten damit sie sich noch besser auf
die Vermittlung in dauerhafte Jobs
konzentrieren können auch dafür brauchen
wir jetzt und heute und hier die
Abstimmung
deshalb bitte ich Sie
dieser wichtigen aufsetzung des
Ergebnisses des Vermittlungsausschusses
zuzustimmen und allem DemokratInnen und
Demokraten
in diesem Haus rufe ich zu stimmen Sie
diesem Gesetz zu es stärkt die Menschen
es stärkt die zusammen den Zusammenhalt
und damit unser Land Hartz IV ist damit
Geschichte
nächster Redner zur Geschäftsordnung von
der afd-fraktion Stephan Brandner
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
wir befinden uns ja hier in einer kurzen
Geschäftsordnungsdebatte weil wir von
der Opposition also wir von der
Alternative für Deutschland und dagegen
wären dass die heutige Tagesordnung
völlig grundlos und hektisch um das
Thema Bürgergeld von der wahrscheinlich
ganz Großen Koalition aus hellbraun und
schwarz erweitert werden soll abgesehen
davon dass wir
abgesehen davon dass wir den sogenannten
Kompromiss der
hellbraun-schwarzen inhaltlich ablehnen
war das Vermittlungsverfahren dass sie
ein Artikel 77 Grundgesetz quasi
verfassungskrankheit eine Phase noch
bevor sich die Ausschuss nach Artikel 77
Grundgesetz überhaupt konstituiert hatte
nämlich am kommen am vergangenen
Mittwoch also vorgestern verkündeten die
stritten sie ja aus der hellbraun und
der schwarzen Ecke bereits Anfang der
Woche stolz ihr Ergebnis dass sie
irgendwelchen Hinterzimmern ausge Schuld
hatten unter Umgehung des
verbindungsausschusses und Ausgrenzung
der Opposition also der Alternative für
Deutschland denn cducsu und Linke
durften da irgendwie mit dem Auto meine
Damen und Herren so funktioniert gelebte
Demokratie in Deutschland Regierung und
Altparteien mauschen und sich an
Grundgesetz an Vermittlungsausschuss und
der wahren Opposition vorbei kummeln zu
Lasten der Bürger und dann soll der
Bundestag auch noch im Schweizer Galopp
diesen Frauen Kompromiss abnicken wir
von der AFD wollen das nicht und sie von
den selbst ernannten qualitätsdemokraten
so und das auch nicht wollen
labern sich nicht labern sich nicht nur
vom Grundgesetz und der Demokratie leben
und achten Sie Grundgesetz und
Demokratie und unsere Demokratie haben
sie Respekt vor dem Grundgesetz und
unserer Demokratie meine Damen und
Herren und wenn sie das alles das alles
was ich in den letzten anderthalb
Minuten erzählt habe nicht überzeugt
haben sollte überzeugt sie vielleicht
das folgende Zitat es entspricht eben
auch dem guten parlamentarischen Brauch
dass man die Haushaltsdebatten hier im
Deutschen Bundestag wo es um das
Königsrecht des Parlaments geht nicht
mit haushaltsfremden Sache Debatten
zusätzlich belastet das hat gute Gründe
wie diskutieren über ein Haushalt der
fast eine halbe Billion Euro umfasst
darauf wollen wir und darauf müssen wir
uns fokussieren und darauf müssen wir
uns konzentrieren im übrigen an diesem
parlamentarischen brauch hält sich auch
wenn man so will die Opposition in
dieser Woche gab es keine Fragestunde es
gab keine regierungsbefragung und es gab
keine
Stunde aber innovationsfraktionen
scheren sich nicht darum in einer wie
man hier schon sagen kann großen
Arroganz Zitat Ende
einer lächelt schon meine Damen und
Herren wer sagte das war ziemlich genau
72 Stunden von diesem Rednerpult aus ich
verrate es ihnen der lächelnde Thorsten
Frey der erste parlamentarische
Geschäftsführer jetzt
cducsu-bundestagsfraktion also vor drei
Tagen vor drei Tagen hat der frei
und lehrt wie wichtig es ist unbelastet
haushaltswochen begehen zu können und
fachfremdes draußen zu halten ich bin
gespannt der frei wie Sie sich jetzt
hier und heute Verhalten ich habe so ein
Gefühl als wenn sie inzwischen aus der
Opposition in den letzten 72 Stunden in
die Regierung gewechselt sind und sich
heute hier zu verlängerten Armen der
Regierung machen werden ich hoffe es
nicht denn sie sind mir wirklich sehr
sympathisch und ich wünsche mir dass ich
sie nicht so kommen
[Applaus]
als nächstes hat das Wort zur
Geschäftsordnung für die
cdu/csu-fraktion Thorsten frei
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich will es versuchen ganz
sachlich zu machen
und
und möchte an dieser Stelle einfach
sagen wir haben hier ein Verfahren des
verfassungs- und
geschäftsordnungsgemäß ist und ich finde
einfach dass wenn man in der Sache
nichts beizutragen hat das nicht dazu
führen sollte dass man unsere
Institutionen und Verfahren
verunglimpfen sollte
Herr Kollege Brandner hat das was sie an
Fragen aufgeworfen haben in ihrer Rede
ist keine offene Frage mehr sondern das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat mit einer
Entscheidung im Jahr 2015 diese Frage
geklärt und hat sehr eindeutig
formuliert dass der
Vermittlungsausschuss selbstverständlich
zur Vorbereitung eines politischen
Kompromisses zwischen Bundestag und
Bundesrat sich hören Sie bitte zu sich
informeller und vor Männer Gremien
bedienen darf
die nicht der spiegelbildlichkeit
unterliegen wenn es einer
einigungsfindung nützt und hat damit
klargestellt dass der
Vermittlungsausschuss eben etwas
Besonderes ist nämlich ein Gremium
zwischen Bundestag und Bundesrat und
nicht gleichbedeutend ist mit einem
Ausschuss des Deutschen Bundestages
diese Frage ist damals auf Klage der
Linken eindeutig vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht entschieden
worden und deshalb ist es auch in
Ordnung so ich kann für unsere Fraktion
sagen wir halten dieses Verfahren nicht
nur für verfassungs- und
geschäftsordnungsgemäß es ist auch eine
große Stärke unserer parlamentarischen
und föderalen Demokratie dass wir bei
aller Unterschiedlichkeit in der Sache
eine Lösung finden zueinander zu kommen
zugunsten unseres Landes und der
Menschen in unserem Land ist es eine
große Stärke und deswegen werden wir der
aufsetzung dieses Gesetzes dieses
einigungsvorschlages auch zustimmen und
ich will sagen
wir tun es aus Überzeugung weil wir der
Auffassung sind
dass die Ergebnisse des
Vermittlungsausschusses eben nicht in
der Kategorie von Sieger und besiegten
zu beurteilen ist sondern es geht um
eine gute eine bestmögliche Lösung die
liegt heute vor wir haben es geschafft
durch intensive Beratungen ein Ergebnis
des Vermittlungsausschusses zu erreichen
das an den Grundprinzipien des Förderns
und Forderns festhält wir haben es
geschafft diejenigen in den Mittelpunkt
zu rücken die als Leistungsempfänger
davon betroffen sind aber auch
diejenigen die in den Jobcentern
arbeiten und auch diejenigen und
deswegen ist es einigungsergebnis auch
so gut die dafür bezahlen die unseren
Sozialstaat
tragen und damit dafür sorgen dass eben
dieses Geld ihr eigenes Geld nicht
bedingungslos ausgezahlt wird die
Geschäftsordnung des
Vermittlungsausschusses sagt das
Ergebnisse als bald dem Bundestag auf
der Tagesordnung vorgelegt werden sollen
das machen wir jetzt mit der heutigen
Sitzung deswegen hier stimmen wir auch
der aufsetzung zu als bald und damit
schaffen und gewährleisten wir auch das
bereits zum ersten Januar 2023 die
Regelsatzerhöhung möglich ist das ist
gut aus unserer Sicht ist die
Dringlichkeit damit gegeben es ist
verfassungs- und geschäftsordnungsgemäß
deswegen stimmen wir dem zu herzlichen
Dank
wir kommen nun zur Abstimmung
dass die Beschlussempfehlung des
Vermittlungsausschusses zum
bürgergeldgesetz auf die Tagesordnung
gesetzt wird wer stimmt dafür
das sind die Fraktionen die Linke SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen FDP cdu/csu wer
stimmt dagegen das ist die afd-fraktion
Enthaltungen
sehe ich nicht damit ist sie aufsetzung
beschlossen
ich rufe auf den soeben aufgesetzten
Zusatzpunkt 7 Beschlussempfehlung des
Vermittlungsausschusses auf Drucksache
4600 zu dem Gesetz zur Änderung des
zweiten Buches Sozialgesetzbuch und
anderer Gesetze Einführung eines
Bürgergeldes
Berichterstatterin im Bundestag ist die
Abgeordnete Katja Mast Berichterstatter
im Bundesrat ist Ministerpräsident Boris
rein als Berichterstatterin des
Bundestages hat Abgeordnete Katja Mast
eine Protokollerklärung des der
Bundesregierung zu Protokoll gegeben
der Bundesregierung her im
Vermittlungsausschuss so ist es richtig
mir wurde mitgeteilt dass das Wort für
Erklärungen nach § 10 Absatz 2 der
geschäftsordnungsvermittlungsausschusses
gewünscht wird das Wort hat zuerst für
die SPD-Fraktion Dagmar Schmidt
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich freue mich
heute das Ergebnis des
Vermittlungsausschusses für meine
Fraktion bewerten zu dürfen denn für die
SPD-Fraktion ist heute ein wirklich
schöner Tag
und zunächst einmal möchte ich
[Applaus]
dafür dass wir ein tolles Gesetz hier im
Bundestag beschlossen haben und danke an
Hubertus Heil und das Ministerium dafür
dass Sie viel Zeit und Kraft in das
Gesetz aber auch in die Einigung im
Vermittlungsausschuss und mit dem
Bundesrat investiert haben und ich
möchte mich ganz ausdrücklich bedanken
bei den unionsgeführten Ländern vorneweg
Herr Minister Laumann die eine sachliche
Diskussion über das Bürgergeld
ermöglicht haben trotz der Debatten der
letzten Wochen denn ob wir zur Mehrheit
im Bundestag auch eine Mehrheit im
Bundesrat bekommen das war nicht sicher
aber gerade in Zeiten wie diesen ist es
wichtig dass DemokratInnen und
Demokraten Kompromisse finden statt sich
zu blockieren das ist gelungen dafür
allen Beteiligten der Ampel und der
Union ein großes Dankeschön
heute ist für uns ein guter Tag weil wir
Hartz IV hinter uns lassen ich habe in
den letzten Tagen der Gespräche um das
Bürgergeld mal wieder unser
sozialstaatskonzept von vor drei Jahren
in die Hand genommen wir haben darin
aufgeschrieben was wir für die Menschen
die arbeiten tun wollen unter anderem
ein Mindestlohn von 12 Euro haben wir
schon eine Kindergrundsicherung kommt
noch mehr Tarifbindung und Mitbestimmung
vieles andere mehr was wir auf der
Agenda haben und wir haben
aufgeschrieben was wir für die Menschen
machen wollen die arbeiten wollen aber
nicht können Sie wollen wir stärken ihn
mehr Respekt entgegenbringen ihn mehr
Rechte mehr Schutz und mehr Möglichkeit
geben und alles das erreichen wir heute
mit dem Bürgergeld
uns geht es mit der umstrittenen
Karenzzeit gerade um diejenigen die
schon viel geleistet haben die ihren Job
verloren haben und die nicht schnell
wieder einen neuen finden weil sie
vielleicht schon älter sind oder länger
krank oder Selbstständige die keinen
Schutz durch die
Arbeitslosenversicherung haben der
vorübergehende Bezug des Bürgergeldes
wirkt sich nun nicht sofort auf die
Wohnung oder das Ersparte aus leider nur
ein statt zwei Jahre aber das ist
trotzdem ein guter Schutz der vielen
hilft
und mit denen die schon lange draußen
sind oder die es aus der Bahn geworfen
hat sind wir bereit auch einen längeren
Weg zu gehen und wir haben für diesen
Weg mit dem kooperationsplan und einem
Schlichtungsverfahren die
Arbeitssuchenden mit ihren Vorstellungen
gestärkt der Gedanke der
Partnerschaftlichkeit steht im Zentrum
der Zusammenarbeit zwischen Jobcenter
und Arbeitssuchenden und dazu haben wir
die Möglichkeiten für eine passgenaue
Unterstützung ausgeweitet die
Möglichkeit einer dreijährigen
Ausbildung die Ausweitung des sozialen
Arbeitsmarktes ein
weiterbildungsbonuscoaching und vieles
andere mehr hier findet der Kulturwandel
statt nicht mehr schnelle Vermittlungen
in irgendeinen Job sondern nachhaltige
Vermittlung in einen guten Job und
Zusammenarbeit auf Augenhöhe das ist der
Paradigmenwechsel kommen Sie bitte zum
Schluss ich möchte mit einem Zitat von
Helmut enden die Demokratie lebt vom
Kompromiss wer keine Kompromisse machen
kann ist für die Demokratie nicht zu
gebrauchen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir haben einen guten
Kompromiss ich bitte um ihre Zustimmung
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
Hermann Gröhe
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen liebe
Kollegen die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion stimmt dem
Ergebnis des Vermittlungsausschusses zu
wir stimmen zu weil dieses Ergebnis das
Gesetz dass wir in diesem Hause vor zwei
Wochen abgelehnt haben in ganz
grundsätzlicher Weise verändert und es
ist ja bemerkenswert es ist ja
bemerkenswert dass in den letzten Tagen
an diesem Gesetz vor allen Dingen Dinge
gelobt werden vom Hinzuverdienst bis zu
den Regelsätzen die eins gemeinsam haben
sie sind von uns im
Gesetzgebungsverfahren zu keinen
Zeitpunkt kritisiert worden
kritisiert hat die Union in diesem Hause
haben die arbeitsministerinnen und
Arbeitsminister aus den rein der Union
in den Bundesländern grundsätzliche
Webfehler die die Balance von fördern
und fördern betreffen die die
Nachrangigkeit einer steuerlich
finanzierten Sozialleistung gegenüber
der Inanspruchnahme eines nicht
unerheblichen eigenen Vermögens und hier
verändert der Vermittlungsausschuss das
Ergebnis der bundestagsberatung ganz
grundsätzlich
ich nenne das Beispiel der sogenannten
vertrauenszeit sie wird eben nicht
verändert sie wird eben nicht verkürzt
sie wird abgeschafft und sie selbst
haben diese vertrauenszeit als ein
wesentliches Element ihrer Reform
bezeichnet sie wird abgeschafft die
Praktiker in den Jobcentern sagen gut so
und wir verändern die
Karenzzeit wir verändern da die Grenzen
für die in anspruchnahmeeigenen
Vermögens das stärkt die Fairness in
unserem Sozialstaat meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren ich glaube das ist ein
gutes Ergebnis 74% der Bevölkerung
teilen die Auffassung dass diese
Korrektur notwendig und richtig war wir
wünschen dass die Instrumente dieses
Gesetzes jetzt genutzt werden deswegen
bedauern wir es dass die Ampel die
Chance dieser haushaltswoche ungenutzt
hat verstreichen lassen unsere Jobcenter
besser auszustatten um dieser Arbeit
gerecht werden zu können meine Damen
meine Herren
ob wir Hartz IV überwinden
entscheidet sich nicht an der
Umbenennung einer Sozialleistung sondern
daran ob es uns gelingt mehr Menschen in
Arbeit zu vermitteln darum muss es gehen
und ich möchte von dieser Stelle aus
auch die Wirtschaft auffordern die
Möglichkeiten etwa des von uns
geschaffen und jetzt infristeten
sozialen Arbeitsmarktes zu nutzen
Menschen auch durch die in Anspruchnahme
von lohnzuschüssen Teilhabe auf Arbeit
zu ermöglichen dieser Kompromiss trägt
die Handschrift der Unionsfraktion
deswegen stimmen wir gerne zu
nächste Rednerin für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen Britta Hasselmann
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren ich begründe kurz warum
ich dem vermittlungsergebnis zugestimmt
habe und meine Fraktion die es gleich
auch tun wird nämlich das ist Sinn der
Aussprache wenn es überhaupt eine gibt
zu dem Punkt
annahmevermittlungsergebnis es geht auch
nicht darum ob irgendwer irgendeine
Handschrift hat oder nicht es geht um
die Menschen im Land und um die
Unterstützung der Menschen
die Ermutigung und Hilfe benötigen meine
Damen und Herren das Bürgergeld kommt
und mit ihm die Regelsatzerhöhung das
ist gut und wichtig und das ist das
Mindeste was wir in dieser
Krisensituation tun können darüber
hinaus wird es ein Vorrang
für umgeben der vermittlungsvorrang
fällt und das ist ein ganz wichtiges
Signal für die Menschen denn der dritte
Effekt den viele Betroffene erlebt haben
in der Vergangenheit endet damit es geht
nicht mehr darum Menschen einfach in
irgendwas zu vermitteln und dann in ein
paar Monaten sie wieder im Jobcenter zu
haben sondern jetzt sind Qualifizierung
und Weiterbildung ein ganz klarer und
wichtiger Akzent dieser
bürgergeld-reform und das ist wichtig
und richtig und deshalb gut so
ein zweiter Punkt ist die
vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit auch hier
gibt es einen klaren Vorgang und das ist
eine klare Veränderung zur alten ALG2
Gesetzgebung sie ist bedeutend für alle
Menschen die Hilfe und Unterstützung in
Anspruch nehmen denn das heißt Beratung
und Coaching und alles was im Jobcenter
für Menschen die Unterstützung und
Beratung brauchen läuft auf Augenhöhe
und das hat dieses Gesetz noch mal klar
zum Ausdruck gebracht das ist wichtig
und gut so der dritte Punkt es gibt
einen klaren Vorrang für Kooperation der
ist festgeschrieben durch einen
kooperationsplan durch einen
schlichtungsmechanismus darüber hinaus
gibt es
Hinzuverdienstmöglichkeiten ich glaube
dass mit diesem Gesetz ein groß Schritt
getan ist wirklich jetzt eine
Sozialreform auf den Weg zu bringen die
auf Ermutigung und Unterstützung setzt
und das ist für die betroffenen Menschen
im Land ganz bedeutend und da geht es
nicht im Kleinklein darum wir irgendeine
Handschrift irgendwo hingesetzt hat
meine Damen und Herren und lassen sie
mich zum Schluss noch sagen ich fand die
Debatte im Vermittlungsausschuss sehr
sachorientiert es gab keine Polemik es
gab keine soziale Spaltung es gab keine
Diffamierung von Menschen die in Not und
Armut leben und eine Spaltung in die die
Arbeit haben und die die keiner haben
und die Methode Populismus hatte im
Vermittlungsausschuss und empfinden
dieses Ergebnisses überhaupt keinen Raum
das war gut so meine Damen und Herren
und ich habe mich Zeit gefragt ob es
daran liegt dass Friedrich Merz und
Markus Söder nicht dabei waren danke
nächster Redner für die FDP-Fraktion
Johannes Vogel
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
dass in unserer Demokratie sich ein
Gesetz weiterentwickelt nach einem
ersten Entwurf des zuständigen Ministers
dann nach Beratung in der Koalition und
dann wenn unsere Verfassung das vorsieht
auch in einem Vermittlungsverfahren das
ist ein ganz normales demokratisches
Verfahren und wir haben als Koalition
von Anfang an gesagt Anspruch muss sein
in der Sache zu diskutieren und ein
gutes Gesetz noch besser zu machen und
das ist gelungen mit dem Vorschlag der
heute hier vorliegt und deswegen werde
ich als Mitglied des
Vermittlungsausschusses und meine
Fraktion gleich auch zustimmen und ich
will kurz erläutern warum erstens klar
war und ist Fördern und Fordern gilt
auch beim Bürgergeld und es gut dass das
jetzt unmissverständlich auch für jeden
in diesem Land klar ist meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
klar ist auch dass die Grundsicherung
enorm reformbedürftig war wir mussten
sie doch moderner und unbürokratischer
machen wir gaben 60 Millionen Euro aus
jedes Jahr um 18 Millionen Euro Cent
Beträge wieder einzutreiben Menschen
mussten am Anfang im Hartz-IV-System
sich am Anfang wenn Sie in einer durch
einen Schicksalsschlag in eine
Lebenskrise kommen Details ihres
Mietvertrags diskutieren erspart es
aufbrauchen all das wird Bürgern beim
Bürgergeld nicht mehr zugemutet und das
ist eine gute Modernisierung der
Grundsicherung insbesondere können Sie
auch Ihre Altersvorsorge behalten weil
auch in Lebenskrisen wollen wir
Eigenverantwortung und Vorsorge
bestrafen und nicht belohnen und das
eine gute Modernisierung liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
aber
der Kern der Kern des Bürgergeldes ist
wirklich dass wir unsere Grundsicherung
fairer und
aufstiegsorientierter machen und das
sieht man übrigens auch an den Zahlen
von der Verbesserung der
zuverdienstregeln für die wir als Freie
Demokraten viele viele Jahre gekämpft
haben profitieren direkt über eine halbe
Million Menschen für die es leichter
wird sich Schritt für Schritt
rauszuarbeiten aus der
Hilfsbedürftigkeit eine Brücke zu
betreten wieder in die finanzielle
Selbstständigkeit und das muss doch der
Anspruch unseres Sozialstaat sein liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und ganz besonders wichtig ist das für
die
1,9 Millionen junge Menschen die heute
in sogenannten Hartz-IV-Familien groß
werden dass wir für die mehr Fairness in
diesem Land schaffen die waren mich
bisher in der Situation dass ich ihre
Ausbildung nicht lohnt weil sie wenn sie
eine Ausbildung machen von ihrem
Ausbildungsgehalt nur 200 Euro behalten
können rund beim Bürgergeld werden es
über 600 Euro sein so geht
Leistungsgerechtigkeit liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und
junge Menschen erfahren nicht mehr schon
am Anfang ihres Lebens beim ersten
selbst verdienten Geld dass ich ihre
Anstrengung weniger lohnt wegen der
Familie in die sie geboren wurden das
ist das Gegenteil von
Chancengerechtigkeit unabhängig von der
Herkunft und das schaffen wir endlich ab
in diesem Land liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
bisher musste man
bei der Grundsicherung zu oft
Chancengerechtigkeit im Dunkeln suchen
mit dem Bürgergeld und den besseren
zuverdienstregeln schalten wir das Licht
an und das ist eine sehr gute Nachricht
für unser Land vielen Dank
nächster Redner für die afd-fraktion DR
Götz Frömming
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren geschätzter Kollege frei ich muss
noch mal auf das eingehen was sie eben
sagten also es wundert uns ehrlich
gesagt nicht dass sie das Ergebnis
dieser kugelei hier verteidigen denn sie
haben ja selber mitgeholt und und
übrigens ist das ja auch nicht das erste
Mal dass wir das Erleben schon während
der corona-pandemie fielen die
eigentlichen Entscheidungen eben nicht
in denen von der Verfassung dafür
vorgesehenen Gremien sondern in den
Runden zu den damals Frau Merkel die
Minister eingestellt hat so geht man
nicht mit unserer Verfassung rum um
meine Damen und Herren und wenn sie denn
schon nicht wenn sie denn schon nicht
die Kritik meines Kollegen Brandner
annehmen wollen vielleicht lesen Sie
heute mal den Kommentar der ARD dazu aus
dem hauptstadtbüro der Ardian heißt der
glaube ich der spricht genau das gleiche
aus was Kollege Brandner auch gesagt hat
die Union hat mit ihrem voreiligen
ausplaudern noch vor der Konstituierung
des Ausschusses dem Ansehen unserer
demokratischen Ordnung geschadet
schreibt ein Journalist der ARD meine
Damen und Herren
zur Sache selbst um was geht es hier
denn eigentlich das wird jetzt so als
großer Erfolg verkauft die Wahrheit ist
doch die die Ampel wollte den Begriff
Hartz IV loswerden die Union hat dazu
die Hand gereicht und die Ampel hat
nahezu jedem Kompromiss hier mitgemacht
in Wahrheit haben wir hier keinen
Systemwechsel da kann die Union sich
selbst ein Stückchen auf die Schulter
feiern klopfen aber der Ampel ging es ja
auch gar nicht um einen Systemwechsel
ihnen ging es um einen etikettenwechsel
und das was ihr alle gemeinsam
miteinander machen heute ist ein
Etikettenschwindel und da machen wir
nicht mit meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren
und ich kann ihnen eins prophezeien
diese Etikettenschwindel fliegen früher
oder später immer auf weil die Bürger
ist merken der Begriff Bürgergeld wird
in kurzer Zeit genauso verbrannt sein
wie der Begriff früher mal Asylant
verbrannt wurde wieder Begriff
Flüchtling verbrannt ist wieder Begriff
Fachkraft verbrannt wurde und so weiter
genauso wird der Begriff der Bürgergeld
auch verbrannt sein und und schon heute
können sie ja lesen
[Applaus]
das aus den Kreisen der Union schon
kolportiert wird in Wirklichkeit ist das
nicht das Bürgergeld sondern Hartz 5
meine Damen und Herren
zur Sache selbst haben Sie denn an den
wirklichen Problemen dieses Landes etwas
gelöst vielleicht lesen Sie mal was vor
kurzem anonym natürlich weil er sonst in
seinem Job fürchten müsste ein
Mitarbeiter in einem großen sogenannten
Jobcenter gesagt hat
die Mitarbeiter in den Jobcentern
frieren zu Hause mehr teilweise als die
Kunden die zu Ihnen kommen mit dem von
ihnen erzielten Kompromiss wird sich
nichts ändern an der Schieflage in
unserem Sozialsystem wir werden nicht
mehr Menschen in Arbeit bringen wir
werden nichts beseitigen an den
Ungerechtigkeiten sie haben nicht den
Magnet unseres Sozialstaates abgestellt
meine Damen und Herren sie haben von den
wahren großen Problemen dieses Landes
nichts gelöst sie sind das Problem
vielen Dank
nächste Rednerin für die Fraktion DIE
LINKE dr Gesine Lötzsch
hier in der amtsfrau-präsidentin meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren im
Vermittlungsausschuss wurde das Gesetz
nicht verbessert sondern verschlechtert
und darum hat die Linke mit Nein
gestimmt meine Damen und Herren Hermann
Gröhe von der CDU hat es ja geradezu
genüsslich ausgeführt die Ampel hat sich
von der Union bereitwillig über den
Tisch ziehen lassen Widerstand war nicht
zu erkennen das Bürgergeld ist eben
keine Überwindung von Hartz IV es ist
nur ein Täuschungsmanöver meine Damen
und Herren
wir als LINKE wollen Hartz IV
grundsätzlich überwinden die Erhöhung
des Regelsatzes um 53 Euro pro Monat ist
eben kein ausreichender
Inflationsausgleich allein die Preise
für die Grundnahrungsmittel sind in
einem Jahr über 20 Prozent gestiegen der
Paritätische Wohlfahrtsverband fordert
ein Regelsatz von 725 Euro im Monat eine
gute Forderung das Ziel der Linken ist
eine sanktionsfreie Mindestsicherung von
1.200 Euro
meine Damen und Herren auch bei der
Verschärfung der Sanktionen und der
Reduzierung des Schonvermögens hat die
Ampel sehr schnell eine Rolle rückwärts
gemacht so viel Einigkeit zwischen Ampel
und Union war selten und das finde ich
schlimm meine Damen und Herren
Kollegen Britta Hasselmann von den
Grünen hat nun erklärt dass das
Bürgergeld wie sie es vorgeschlagen
hätten im Kern erhalten geblieben wäre
das ist richtig denn der Kern des
Bürgergeldes heißt Hartz IV das ist die
Wahrheit meine Damen und Herren und
Hartz IV soll weiter als droopolisse für
die Menschen aufrecht erhalten werden
die für niedrige Löhne arbeiten müssen
es ist doch nicht zu fassen dass in
unserem Land eine Million Menschen von
ihrem Lohn nicht leben können sie müssen
zum Amt gehen und aufstocken die
Arbeitgeber bezahlen die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter zu
schlecht und die Steuerzahlerinnen und
Steuerzahler sind gezwungen die Löhne
aufzubessern das ist nicht zu
akzeptieren dass es würde los meine
Damen und Herren
11 Prozent der Nutzer der Tafel sind
Menschen die Vollzeit arbeiten das sagt
doch viel über den deutschen
Niedriglohnsektor aus der
Niedriglohnsektor muss beseitigt werden
meine Damen und Herren
und auch bei der Reduzierung von schon
Vermögen wurde nicht sachlich diskutiert
sondern ideologisch Niedriglöhner
sollten gegen Arbeitslose aufgehetzt
werden ich frage sie warum gab es
eigentlich nie eine Kampagne der Union
gegen Steuerhinterziehung das spricht
doch Bände meine Damen und Herren
die Menschen in unserem Land werden
immer wieder aufgefordert für das Alter
Geld anzusparen weil die gesetzliche
Rente im nicht mehr ausreiche jetzt
vergreift man sich auch nach einem
Schonvermögen von Menschen die ihre
Arbeit verloren haben das ist schäbig
vor 20 Jahren haben wir Linken gegen
Hartz IV gestimmt weil es Armut per
Gesetz bedeutet wir brauchen endlich
einen wirklichen Systemwechsel das wäre
Würde und Respekt vielen Dank
wir kommen nun zur Abstimmung zur
Abstimmung liegen mehrere persönliche
Erklärungen nach Paragraph 31 unserer
Geschäftsordnung vor
wir stimmen ab gemäß Paragraph 10 Absatz
3 Satz 1 der Geschäftsordnung
über das Ergebnis dass der
vermittlungsausschluss beschlossen hat
wir stimmen nun über die
Beschlussempfehlung des
Vermittlungsausschusses auf Verlangen
der Fraktion der SPD Bündnis 90 die
Grünen FDP namentlich ab die Abstimmung
erfolgt in der westlobby sie haben zur
Abgabe ihrer Stimme nach Eröffnung der
Abstimmung 20 Minuten Zeit
ich bitte die Schriftführerin Schrift
vorgesehenen Plätze einzunehmen das ist
der Fall ich eröffne damit die
namentliche Abstimmung über die
Beschlussempfehlung des
Vermittlungsausschusses auf Drucksache
4.600 die abstimmungsuhren werden in 20
Minuten
um 9:58 Uhr geschlossen das
bevorstehende Ende der namentlichen
Abstimmung wird Ihnen rechtzeitig
bekannt gegeben
wir setzen nun
die Haushaltsberatung fort
ich rufe auf den Einzelplan 09
Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz
mit den Beschlussempfehlungen des
Haushaltsausschusses auf Drucksache
3.5009 und 3526
die Berichterstattung haben die
Abgeordneten Andreas Mattfeld Frank
junge Felix banatschak Carsten klein
wolfgang-perlin
ja meine Damen und Herren jetzt geht es
tatsächlich weiter mit der Debatte mit
der haushaltswoche im Deutschen
Bundestag und es geht um den Etat des
Bundeswirtschaftsministers bzw des
Bundesministers für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz wir haben heute morgen im
Interview auch schon mal drüber
gesprochen 14,5 Milliarden Euro hat der
zu Verfügung für die Förderung
beispielsweise Kündigung zukünftiger
Technologien wie Mobilität Luft und
Raumfahrt aber in erster Linie stehen
natürlich Energie Nachhaltigkeit und
Klimaschutz im Vordergrund jetzt kommt
auch der Bundesminister fix wieder in
den Plenarsaal zurückgelaufen nachdem er
seine Stimme abgegeben hat zum Thema
Bürgergeld bzw dem Ergebnis des
Vermittlungsausschusses zum Bürgergeld
und sobald diese Abstimmung hier
erledigt ist kann er dann auch der
Bundesrat darüber abstimmen darüber
werden wir Ihnen später noch berichten
wir steigen jetzt erstmal ein in die
Debatte zum Einzelplan 09 Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz und ampult ist Andreas
Mattfeld wie wir eben schon gehört haben
der Stadt also einer Fraktion für diesen
Einzelplan
eine Umsteuerung ihres Etats und des
klimatransformationsfonds hinzu
Wirtschaftswachstum hinzu
wirtschaftsstabilität vornehmen leider
meine Damen und Herren muss ich
feststellen dass sie gerade in diesen
notwendigen Bereichen nur ganz ganz
wenig fast schon homöopathische
Veränderungen vorgenommen haben und
erscheint Herbeck für sie steht nur
Klimapolitik im Fokus und dabei habe ich
doch häufig den Eindruck auch wenn ich
sie anschaue dass sie nahezu körperlich
die massiven Wirtschaft und
Wohlstandsverlust in unserem Land spüren
sie nehmen diesen aber in Kauf weil ihre
vermutlich Jahrzehnte lang antrainierte
ideologisch grüne DNA auf Ablehnung von
Industrie auf Ablehnung von Handwerk und
vor allen Dingen auch Ablehnung von
Hochtechnologie ausgerechnet ist und
damit Herr habe da meine ich nicht nur
den Weiterbetrieb der dringend
benötigten Kapazitäten der
Kernkraftwerke über den April hinaus
sie fördern und das sehen wir ganz
deutlich in diesem Haus lieber das
Lastenfahrrad anstelle der so wichtigen
Arbeitsplätze in der Hochtechnologie wie
zum Beispiel der maritimen Wirtschaft
sie setzen die Axt an bei der für den
Export so wichtigen Außenwirtschaft und
sie kürzende nachgeordneten Bereichen
die gerade für die Wirtschaft nahezu
vielfach schon als Dienstleister von
besonderer Bedeutung sind massiv sie
kürzen zugunsten ihrer grünen Ideologie
nahezu in allen Bereichen mit
Ausstrahlung auf Forschung mit
Ausstrahlung auf Bildung mit
Ausstrahlung auf Arbeitsplätze der
Zukunft und auf neue Branche und habe
ich kann sie nicht ersparen sie
gefährden somit den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland und viele in den Medien
gegeben in diesen Tagen ja das Wort raus
von der die Industrialisierung unseres
Landes ich will gar nicht so weit wie
das zuzutrauen aber ein bisschen Kern
liegt darin schon und dabei merken Sie
doch schon wie verzweifelt die Menschen
die verzweifelt vor allem auch die
Unternehmen in unserem Land sind
Fachkräftemangel Rohstoffmangel
Inflation Energiepreise abreißende
Lieferketten lassen doch unsere
Wirtschaft und lassen auch die Menschen
von Tag zu Tag nervöser werden sie
reagieren hierauf die reagieren hier
drauf nahezu immer zu spät und vor allen
Dingen reagieren sie falsch meine Damen
und Herren und das
mussten wir leider leidvoll auch bei
diesen Haushaltsberatungen gerade im
Bereich der Energiepolitik mehrfach
erleben Herr habe es wäre klug gewesen
dass sie sich dem Paket der Union für
Wirtschaftswachstum und Fachkräfte
Sicherung nicht komplett verschlossen
hätten in all den Jahren zumindest
unserer Regierungszeit haben wir als
Union gerade für Ihr Haus dort wo auch
ihre grüne Fraktion die FDP Anträge
eingebracht hat diese immer mal wieder
gemeinsam auf dem Weg gebracht gerade
auch weil es mir ganz persönlich wichtig
war nach außen zu dokumentieren dass
Demokraten doch mehr Gemeinsamkeiten als
den Trennendes haben
dass sie diese
geübte Zusammenarbeit jetzt komplett
eingestellt haben das zeigt mir
zumindest dass sie ausschließlich auf
Trennung als den auf verbindendes
Aussehen wir
wir als Union wir sehen das anders und
deshalb haben wir
zahlreiche Anträge die wir von ihrer
Seite für nachvollziehbar gehalten haben
zugestimmt sie hingegen haben alle aber
wirklich alle unsere Anträge zu
abgebügelt so wollten sie keine 195
Millionen Euro für handwerkliche Berufe
in unterschiedlichen Programmen frei
machen damit wollten wir gerade den
jungen Menschen im Handwerk doch
signalisieren welch ein besonderen
Stellenwert ihre Ausbildung für unser
Land hat von der Ampel abgelehnt nicht
mal die Nachnutzung der ausgeförderten
gastfeldern durch Geothermie wollten sie
mitmachen oder unseren Antrag zu den
erforderlichen 1,4 Milliarden Euro für
die Raumfahrt Industrie damit wir
bereits in diesem Haushalt unsere
nationalen und internationalen
Verpflichtungen klar Abbinden wir
wollten und wollen diese
Hochtechnologien an deutschen Standorten
und ich darf das auch sagen wir hatten
jetzt die ministerratskonferenz wir
wollen die Atem des Mondmission und
gemeinsam mit dem Amerikaner deutsche
Astronauten auf dem Mond zu entsenden
denn gerade die Atem müssen Mission
meine Damen und Herren die ist wichtig
um auch junge Menschen für
zukunftsweisende hightech-berufe zu
begeistern denn eines Herr Habeck ich
glaube da müssen wir häufiger mal drüber
reden das dürfte aber klar sein nur mit
gender Studenten nur mit denen ihnen
sehr nahestehenden klimaaktivisten da
bauen Sie in unserem Land nicht eine
Wärmepumpe ein
und an einer Stelle er Habeck und das
möchte ich ausdrücklich an ihre möchte
ich ausdrücklich an ihre Stelle auch an
Frau Dr Christmann sagen da erkenne ich
es ausdrücklich an dass wir bei der
Vorbereitung der ESA
ministerratskonferenz zur Raumfahrt
Fahrt intensiv gesprochen haben und dass
wir diese Konferenz gemeinsam
vorbereitet haben es war immer gute
Tradition dass wir zumindest bei
internationalen Aktivitäten über
fraktionell handeln und deshalb danke
dass Sie die von uns in den Blickpunkt
in der Vergangenheit gerückten Projekte
jetzt fortführen dass Sie auch unsere
Vorschläge wie Exo Mars die Ariane
Rakete mit einem selbständigen
europäischen Zugang zum all und die
artemismission dann doch noch
mitgetragen und dass sie diese
gezeichnet haben
dennoch abschließend zum Schluss mein
Rat Herr Kollege Harbeck nehmen Sie den
Bereich Wirtschaft im Namen ihres
Ministeriums ernster Dennis gerade die
Menschen in Industrieproduktion und
Handwerk die den Karren in unserem Land
ziehen diese Menschen wollen auch in
Zukunft in ihren Unternehmen anständig
Geld verdienen und nicht durch eine
realitätsferne Politik ihren Job
verlieren herzlichen Dank
Andreas Mattfeld war das in der Debatte
über den Einzelplan 09 Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz der hier jetzt diskutiert
wird und in dieser Debatte spricht jetzt
die italienische Check der
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecher der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin unser
Berichterstatter Felix bannaschak kann
heute auf eines Grund eines sehr
erfreulichen persönlichen Umstandes
nicht an der Debatte teilnehmende
deswegen nicht das heute in die Hand
auch zu danken den hauselter:innen für
die umfangreiche Arbeit der letzten
Wochen und Monate diesen
Regierungsentwurf zu verbessern und 790
Millionen Euro umzuschichten übrigens
Herr Mattfeld in Richtung der Zukunft
Investitionen und einen Vorschlag der
von ihnen kam war ja zum Beispiel
internationalen Klimaschutz zu streichen
das ist natürlich kein Beitrag für
Zukunftsfähigkeit ganz im Gegenteil
wir haben die Bereiche Klima- und
Energie mit 420 Millionen Euro
zielführend gestärkt und ausgebaut auch
beim Bereich der Digitalisierung mit 370
Millionen Euro Innovationen und Stärkung
zu Resilienz ausgegeben wir zeigen mit
diesem Haushalt in der Krise wollen wir
in die Zukunft investieren Innovation
ist jetzt das Leitbild was wir brauchen
den du so kommen wir entschlossen aus
der Krise mit erneuerbaren Energien
Energieeffizienz entschlossener
Digitalisierung und das trägt diesem
Haushalt Rechnung
ich warne auch da vorher Mattfeld und
das erlebe ich in den letzten Wochen
sehr intensiv dass die Union unseren
Standort schlecht redet wir haben ein
schweres Jahr aufgrund des russischen
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine aber wir
haben auch gemeinsam hier im Parlament
vieles auf dem Weg gebracht ich erinnere
jetzt an die Beratung akut zur Gas und
strompreisbremse die Gasspeicher sind
voll die Preise gehen nach unten wir
haben Investitionssicherheit geschaffen
in den letzten Wochen und Monaten daran
müssen wir festhalten und sollten nicht
den Standort schlecht reden in einer
solchen Phase
wir haben uns auch
Zukunftsthemen angenommen ich sehe
unsere Koordinatorin für Luft und
Raumfahrt einer Christmann vielen Dank
dass die Bundesregierung auch vier
Milliarden Euro jetzt auf der ESA
ministerratskonferenz eingebracht hat
dass wir hier diesen wichtigen Bereich
auch entschlossen stärken
auch das Thema noch zu erweitern auch
für die Grace klimasatelliten haben wir
134 Millionen für die anschlussmissionen
auf den Weg gebracht ist auch ein
wichtiger Meilenstein für die
Klimaforschung also sie sehen wir
kümmern uns intensiv um die Bereiche die
uns aus der Krise rausführen
Krisenbewältigung ist dieses Jahr aber
es geht jetzt entschlossen darum
Sicherheit Zuversicht zu schaffen fürs
kommende Jahr daran arbeiten wir sehr
intensiv
ein Thema was uns sehr umtreibt ist das
Thema wirtschaftliche Souveränität wir
geben über 879 Millionen Euro für die
Mikroelektronik aus im Rahmen der
websiteprogramme das heißt wir wollen
eine Standort Deutschland Europa das
betone ich ganz besonders wir müssen die
europäisch denken stärken das heißt
europäische Souveränität ist deutsches
Interesse und auch das bildet sich in
diesem Haushalt ab
der Einzelplan 09 hat ja den Mittelstand
als einen besonderen Fokus gerade kleine
und mittlere Unternehmen sind uns ein
besonderes Anliegen hier die
industrielle Gemeinschaftsforschung
haben wir mit 20 Millionen Euro gestärkt
und natürlich ist es essenziell dass wir
jetzt auch den Mittelstand bei der
Transformation Stärken deswegen freue
ich mich sehr dass es auch gelungen ist
ein Transformationsprogramm für klein
und kleines Unternehmen im Wert von 100
Millionen Euro auf den Weg zu bringen zu
können zum Beispiel dann Bäckereien
Metzgereien ihre
Transportprozess Energie umstellen dass
es sehr wichtig für unsere Zukunft
es ist ein schwieriges Jahr für uns alle
ich glaube mancher freut sich wenn das
Jahr vielleicht auch vorübergeht aber
wir wissen das nächste wird nicht
unbedingt leicht
ich will trotzdem auch Danke sagen bei
all den Streitigkeiten die wir hier im
Parlament hatten haben wir auch vieles
gemeinsam bewerkstelligt und das ist
glaube ich auch wichtig dass wir
gemeinsam den Weg nach vorne suchen der
russische Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine
er ist nicht überwunden die Menschen
dort leiden wir investieren hier wir
schaffen Sicherheit auch soziale
Sicherheit wir werden das Thema
Fachkräfte in den Fokus nehmen in den
kommenden Wochen und Monaten auch das
ist sehr wichtig dass wir hier
Vorankommen aber es bleibt essentiell
dass wir in europäischer Gemeinsamkeit
investieren dass wir Sicherheit schaffen
und das legen wir mit diesem Haushalt
mit diesem Einzelplan 09 vor ich danke
Dieter Janecek war das der
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecher der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen nächster
Redner hier wird Wolfgang wiele sein aus
der afd-fraktion und das gibt mir die
Gelegenheit schnell noch mal was zu
sagen zu der Einlassung von Stefan
Brandner vorhin in der geod-batte der
hat er ja dagegen sich ausgesprochen
dass das bürgergeldgesetz hier noch mal
diskutiert und vor allem auch abgestimmt
wird
weil er gesagt hat die haushaltswoche
habe doch da unbedingt ein voran da
müssen wir mal erinnern an gestern
Nachmittag da hat der Bundestag nämlich
beispielsweise über das Energie
sicherungsgesetz abgestimmt über die
energiepreispauschale für Studierende
und über die Lkw-Maut also entweder
abgestimmt oder den Gesetzentwurf
eingebracht da gab es übrigens keinerlei
Einwände seitens der afd-fraktion das
wollte ich zur gesamte Wahrheit und zum
Gesamtbild noch beitragen und jetzt
haben wir Wolfgang viele zu tun
und dass Deutschland sich besonders
reinhängen müsse damit die restlichen 98
Prozent der Welt folgen das verbreiteten
sie Herr Minister Habeck kürzlich auf
Instagram
diese Geschichten sind eine gefährliche
Mischung aus Selbstüberschätzung und
Selbstbetrug
die ideologische Energiewende hat uns
vom Gas in gefährlicher Weise abhängig
gemacht denn mit Wind und Sonne alleine
kann man einen Industrieland nicht
betreiben
die Sanktionen gegen Russland dienen
ganz sicher nicht deutschen Interessen
und sie wurden ohne gründliches
Nachdenken losgetreten
andere Länder für die Ungarn Tschechien
und die Slowakei schützen ihre
Wirtschaft und ihre Bürger viel besser
als diese deutsche ampelregierung
die Energiepreise jagen nun von Rekord
zur Rekord ein paar Jahrzehnte nach dem
Wirtschaftswunder steht Deutschland nun
vor dem wirtschaftsabgrund und der die
Industrialisierung täglich schreiben
Wirtschaftslenker brandbriefe nach
Berlin
viele Unternehmen stellen die Produktion
ein der Bäcker nebenan ist dann
natürlich bald pleite große Unternehmen
wie BASF verlassen Deutschland für viele
Bürger heißt das heute müssen sie zu
Hause frieren morgen ist auch die Arbeit
weg
mit preisbremsen immer neuen Milliarden
Paketen für Juniper Seefeld the und so
weiter legt die Regierung dem Patienten
Deutschland eine Infusionsnadel nach der
anderen
alle diese Infusion bringen aber keine
Heilung wenn das Ausbluten der deutschen
Volkswirtschaft nicht gestoppt wird
Wumms macht das sonst nur in der
Staatskasse und bald danach beim
Steuerzahler
wenn sie nicht als
abwirtschaftungsminister in die
Geschichte eingehen wollen habe ich dann
beheben Sie jetzt die wirklichen
Ursachen dieser Krise
legen sie ihre Ideologie auf die Seite
beenden Sie Energiewende und
wirtschaftsaktion
lassen Sie die Kernkraftwerke länger
laufen nicht nur ein paar Monate sondern
für Jahre
folgen Sie der Forderung aus der
Wirtschaft und lassen sie in nordstream
2 wieder in Betrieb nehmen dem Vernehmen
nach funktioniert eine höhere ja noch
lösen Sie den sogenannten Klima- und
transformationsfonds auf der nichts
anderes ist als ein Schattenhaushalt ein
intransparenter Geldspeicher für ihre
ideologieprojekte
die Zeit des Geschichtenerzählens ist
vorbei Deutschland steht am Scheideweg
wer glaubt dass kleine Deutschland
könnte für den ganzen Erdball
Lehrmeister dafür sein wie man das Klima
rettet
der wird der Ball ganzen Welt bald nur
eines zeigen nämlich wie man sich selbst
ruiniert
reißen sie das rote herum werfen sie
ihre Ideologie beiseite stoppen Sie das
Ausbluten unserer Volkswirtschaft dann
werden sie die AFD auf ihrer Seite haben
mit einer Politik für die Zukunft
Deutschlands aber sicher nicht mit den
Vorstellungen die wir uns hier als
Bundeshaushalt vorgelegt haben
der Bundestag diskutiert über den Etat
des Wirtschafts- und
klimaschutzministers der sich da gerade
auch ein bisschen amüsiert und da sie
sehr aufmerksame Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer sind ist Ihnen garantiert
aufgefallen wie häufig heute hier die
Farbe Orange vertreten ist in Blazern in
Pullover ein T-Shirts habe ich schon
gesehen Krawatten Einstecktücher alle
Varianten sind möglich auch die
Bundestagspräsidentin trägt eine
orangefarbenen Pullover das hat einen
Grund heute ist nämlich internationaler
Tag gegen die Gewalt gegen Frauen er ist
immer am 25 November und orange ist
symbolisiert die Zukunft ohne Gewalt
gegen Frauen also kein Zufall was sie
hier heute entdeckt haben sondern mit
System und durchdacht und mit einem
durchaus guten Grund Frank Junge ist
ampult für die SPD-Fraktion
ein in diesen Zeiten meine Damen und
Herren multipla-krisen und
existenzieller
zukunftsübergreifende Herausforderungen
kommt es auf einen Staat an der in der
Lage ist einen soliden einen sicheren
Haushalt aufzustellen damit es der
Wirtschaft Sicherheit und
Belastungsfähigkeit gibt aber auch den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern und genau das
meine Damen und Herren leisten wir mit
diesem Einzelplan und mit dem gesamten
Haushalt der Bundesregierung wir
entlasten die Bürgerinnen und Bürger in
dreistelliger Milliardenhöhe und ich
sage das noch mal ausdrücklich gerade
auch an die Union gerichtet die vom
Seitenrand immer gerne dicke Backen
macht und hier in einer nörglerischen
Art alles schlecht redet wir schaffen es
als Bundesregierung die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger in der Krise sie alle nicht
allein zu lassen und über
unterschiedliche Maßnahmen so weit zu
entlasten und durch die Krise zu führen
und das spürt auch die Wirtschaft wie
kann es sonst sein dass wir im dritten
Quartal diesen Jahres ein
Wirtschaftswachstum von 0,4% gehabt
haben
das ist wenig das zeigt aber dass wir
auf dem richtigen Kurs sind und die
Wirtschaft mit unseren Möglichkeiten
mitnehmen
meine Damen und Herren der Einzelplan 09
in Verbindung mit den Mitteln aus dem
Transformation und klimafond gibt uns
die Möglichkeit für Energiesicherheit
für unsere Bevölkerung die Wirtschaft zu
sorgen wir stellen uns der Aufgabe dem
Klimawandel weiter zu bekämpfen die
energiewärme und mobilitätswende
voranzubringen und die Transformation
der Wirtschaft ebenso das setzt voraus
oder zieht nach sich dass wir in
riesigen Größenordnungen in die in die
in die Infrastruktur
unseres Landes investieren und dass wir
vor allen Dingen dabei die
Transformation in Richtung Wasserstoff
als Energieträger der Zukunft ausbauen
beziehungsweise Elektromobilität fördern
und vor allen Dingen auch die Sanierung
der der Gebäude auf klimaeffiziente Art
voranbringen dafür geben wir insgesamt
etwa 35 Milliarden Euro aus Geld was
eben nicht nur dafür da ist
Wirtschaftskreisläufe in der Krise zu
stabilisieren Geld was uns dazu das
bringt aus der Krise hinaus in die
Zukunft zu gehen und unseren Standort
für die Zukunft fit zu machen im übrigen
und das will ich auch noch mal sagen im
übrigen haben wir es in einer kurzen
Zeit bis Ende diesen Jahres geschafft
die LNG-Anlage in Wilhelmshaven ans Netz
zu bringen damit wiederum ein Faktor zu
installieren für Energiesicherheit zu
sorgen und Lubmin in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern wird Anfang des
kommenden Jahres folgen das zeigt wie
stark diese Regierung aufgestellt ist
und wie Sie genau die richtigen Weichen
stellt
meine Damen und Herren und das will ich
auch nochmal unterstreichen neben diesem
großen globalen Herausforderungen haben
wir den Schwerpunkt auf den kleinen und
mittelständischen Unternehmen das ist
das Rückgrat unserer Wirtschaft und vor
diesem Hintergrund nehmen wir das mit
Blick auf den Zusammenhalt in der
Gesellschaft sehr ernst vor allen Dingen
diesen Wirtschaftsbereich zu
unterstützen das Mittelstandsprogramm
Zim will ich hier nennen und vor allen
Dingen auch die Industrieforschung für
Unternehmen das sind zwei Programme wo
wir vor allen Dingen kleinen Unternehmen
im strukturschwachen Raum und vor allen
Dingen auch im Osten sehr helfen können
ich will nennen dass wir unter dem
Aspekt des stärkens der Handwerker die
Ausbildung mit 70 Millionen Euro weiter
unterstützen dass wir denen helfen im
Rahmen von Bildungsinfrastruktur gut zu
investieren und ich will ja auch die GRW
nennen die GRW ist noch mal zu den 650
Millionen um weitere 175 Millionen
aufgestockt worden für die nächsten 10
Jahre um damit genau in dem Bereich
nordosthäfen aber auch die Raffinerie
stand im Osten zu unterstützen den
Transformationsprozess entsprechend zu
begleiten das sind genau die richtigen
Investitionen die wir jetzt in der Krise
brauchen und die an dieser Stelle auch
weiter für Sicherheit und für
Beschäftigung sorgen werden meine Damen
und Herren
ganz besonders froh bin ich an der
Stelle auf den Punkt das ist uns wieder
gelungen ist den Wiedereinstieg in das
europäische Programm im say health
vorzunehmen wir haben es dort geschafft
insgesamt in der Ampelkoalition
185 Millionen Euro bis 2028 in die Hand
zu nehmen um an diesem Programm
Synergieeffekte für unsere
Gesundheitsbranche nach sich zu ziehen
wenn es nämlich uns an der Stelle
gelingt Wertschöpfungsprozesse die aus
einem investierten Euro in mehrfacher
Form zu uns zurückkommen bei uns zu
verankern dann hilft das der Branche in
Größenordnung und auch das können wir
mit Blick auf den Wissenstransfer gut
gebrauchen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich komme zum Schluss ich will
zum Ende auch noch mal Dank an alle
Beteiligten Haushälter sagen aber auch
Herr Habeck an ihre Mannschaft im
Ministerium wir haben intensive
Verhandlungen geführt und haben am Ende
einen Haushalt aufstellen können der uns
die Möglichkeit bietet nicht nur gut
durch diese Krise zu kommen
und vor allen Dingen auch die Weichen
für die Zukunft zu stellen und vor dem
Hintergrund darf ich Sie um Zustimmung
bitten
krank Junge war das aus der SPD-Fraktion
berichterstatterie seiner Fraktion für
den Bereich Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz
und ungenau zu sein für den Einzelplan
09 ich schließe damit
die Zählung
das Ergebnis wird in später bekannt
gegeben
wir fahren weiter fort in der Debatte
und dieses später dürfte mutmaßlich in
zehn Jahren vielleicht 15 Minuten sein
denn das ist ja hier relativ schnell
ausgezählt da sind wir dann auch
natürlich noch dabei und können Sie dann
teilhaben lassen an diesem Ergebnis
Christian Laie ist am Pool der ist der
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecher der
Linksfraktion
Frage ist schlecht wie seit langem nicht
um es mit den Worten von Marcel
Fratzscher zu sagen die großen fahren
zum Teil auch in diesen Zeiten dicke
Gewinne ein während viele Mittelständler
die kleinen die Bäckerei um die Ecke
kaum mehr über die Runden kommen und ja
dies ist natürlich auch das Ergebnis des
wirtschaftskriegs mit Russland und wir
lernen Handelskonflikte Konflikte gehen
auf den Nacken der kleinen Leute und ich
sage das deswegen weil die USA Europa in
einen neuen Handelskonflikt drängen will
und diesmal mit China und bevor die
Blockbildung richtig an Fahrt aufnimmt
geht es doch darum die eigenen
Interessen mal zu sortieren und den USA
nicht blind links in den nächsten
Wirtschaftskrieg zu folgen meine Damen
und Herren
und neben den sozialen Kosten gibt es
dafür noch einen Grund und das sind die
Interessen der USA in der Krise haben
sie auf lng-gas aus den USA gesetzt dass
die aber zu Rekordpreisen verkauft haben
selbst Minister Habeck hat sich
gewundert das unter Freunden solche
Mondpreise aufgerufen werden und die
Folge davon ist dass bei solchen
Mondpreisen für Energie natürlich
Industrie Arbeitsplätze hier bedroht
sind und dann wird das
US-Handelsministerium auch noch gezielt
Industrieunternehmen ab und dann sollen
die gigantischen Summen des Inflation
reduction Acts nur fließen wenn die
Industrie auch wirklich in die USA
verlagert wurde und ich sag das mal
deutlich die USA werden aggressiv
zukunftsindustrie und rund um die
erneuerbaren Energien ab und
gleichzeitig fordern sie Gefolgschaft in
einem weiteren Handelskonflikt mit China
dessen Rohstoffe wie aber genau für
diese Zukunft Industrien brauchen und
das bedeutet hier wird eine
reindustrialisierung der USA auf Kosten
einer Deindustrialisierung von Europa
Betrieben meine Damen und Herren tolle
Freunde sind das
und er habe ich
ich bin ja noch nicht so lange dabei
aber ich glaube zwischen Staaten ist das
manchmal wie bei Facebook das heißt nur
Freunde aber in Wahrheit geht es um
etwas anderes und bei Staaten da geht es
um Interessen und ich muss Ihnen sagen
in der globalen in der globalen
Blockbildung vertreten Sie unsere
Interessen bemerkenswert schlecht Herr
Minister so und wer ist uns und unsere
Interessen für Team blau sind das alle
mit dem blonden Haaren und für Team Geld
sind das Menschen mit viel Vermögen auf
der Bank aber wenn ich sage unsere
Interessen dann geht es um die
arbeitenden Menschen da draußen den
Mittelständler die kleinen die Bäckerei
um die Ecke und die werden gerade
schlecht vertreten in der laufenden
Blockbildung kommen diese Menschen unter
die Räder die Schlangen an den Tafeln
sind zu lang wie noch nie mehr als die
Hälfte der Bevölkerung spart inzwischen
beim Essen und deswegen braucht es eine
Wirtschaftspolitik die nicht aus falsch
verstandener Freundschaft in
Handelskonflikte rein stolpern sondern
die die Interessen der Menschen mit
kleinem un weiteren Einkommen
entschlossen und offensiv auch nach
außen vertritt dankeschön
nächster Redner für die FDP-Fraktion
Carsten klein
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Energiekrise stellt die Verbraucherinnen
und Verbraucher die Unternehmerinnen die
Unternehmer die kleinen die mittleren
die großen Unternehmen den Handwerk den
Handel die Industrie vor große
Herausforderungen und wir als
Ampelkoalition SPD Grüne und FDP Stellen
mit dem 200 Milliarden Programm des WSF
ein Programm zur Verfügung dass die
Energiepreise dämpfen wird und mit dem
WSF stellen wir uns an die Seite der
Menschen in diesem Land
und wieder Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse
2023 stellen wir uns an die Seite
zukünftiger Generation denn der WSF ist
ein konzentriertes Instrument das genau
auf die Herausforderung dieser Krise die
Energiepreise zu dämpfen abzielt bei der
gaspreisbremse bei der strompreisbremse
beim Härtefall vor und eben nicht das
Feld aufmacht für viele Ausgabe wünschen
wie wir es ja in der corona-krise bei
den Konjunkturprogrammen erlebt haben
nein ist ein konzentriertes Instrument
das dafür sorgt dass wir auch den Blick
nicht nur auf die Welt um dieser Krise
richten können sondern mit der
Einhaltung der Schuldenbremse auch auf
die Krisen zukünftiger Generation
und es gibt es in diesem Zusammenhang
noch drei wichtige Sachen zu sagen mit
dem WSF nämlich erstens damit es hier
keine Missverständnisse gibt diese
Misere auf dem Energiemarkt die hohen
Preise haben eine Ursache im
Angriffskrieg von Vladimir Putin in der
Ukraine die sind nicht von der
Bundesregierung initiiert und auch nicht
von einem Gas im Bad und das Deutschland
beschlossen hätte so wie es Friedrich
Merz noch im März vorgeschlagen hat und
das zweite was ich sagen möchte ist
jetzt kann man gegen all diese
Vorschläge sein die die Ampelkoalition
zu Recht auf den Weg gebracht hat Liebe
Union aber gleichzeitig keinen eigenen
Vorschlag einzubringen gleichzeitig
keine Haushaltsmittel einzustellen für
die Bekämpfung dieser hohen
Energiepreise das zeigt doch zweierlei
erstens sie lassen die Menschen sie
würden die Menschen in diesem Winter in
Kalten sitzen lassen und zweitens würden
sie dafür sorgen und der ihre
Regierungsführung das nächstes Jahr die
Industrie in diesem Land still steht und
deshalb ist es gut dass die Ampel
regiert und nicht die Union
aber eines möchte ich auch noch klar
adressieren auch im Sinne meiner
Fraktion zu den Verhandlungen die jetzt
in Brüssel stattfinden die Ergebnisse
die dort erzielt werden sollen müssen
selbstverständlich auf den Einigungen in
unserer Koalition auf dieser
Vereinbarungen fundieren und deshalb
will ich nur noch mal darauf hinweisen
dass die Mittel für den WSF im Gegensatz
zu den Plänen der Regierung gesperrt
sind und der Haushaltsausschuss wird die
Mittel diese nötigen Mittel freigeben
wenn die Einigung wenn das was am Ende
beschlossen wird von der Bundesregierung
auf dem Fundament unserer drei
Fraktionen basiert und in keinem anderen
Fall liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und mit dem WSF machen wir eine aktive
Industriepolitik eine aktive
Wirtschaftspolitik im Gegensatz wie
gesagt zu den Ankündigungen der Union
aber Herr Minister sie machen ja auch
noch in einem anderen großen wichtigen
Bereich aktive Wirtschaftspolitik ich
möchte an der Christmann auch herzlich
Glückwünschen beglückwünschen zu dem
Ergebnis dass man den Verhandlungen bei
der esa-konferenz erzielt worden ist 4
Milliarden Euro die Bundesrepublik ist
nach wie vor der stärkste Zahler bei der
europäischen Raumfahrt wir haben uns
klar komm bitte zum Mondprogramm z.B
oder auch zu dem Joint the creamend wenn
wir in Richtung Kleinsatelliten resilien
gekommen wie Kommunikation und
kleinsträger Raketen gehen das ist eine
richtige Weichenstellung dass dann da
noch mal ganz herzlichen Glückwunsch
wir werden diese Entscheidungen aber
auch flankieren wir haben diese
Entscheidung schon flankiert mit
Beschlüssen im Haushaltsausschuss wir
haben gemeinsam lieber Frank gemeinsam
mit Felix dem ich hiervon auch noch mal
herzliche Glückwünsche ausrichten möchte
wir haben gemeinsam 31 Millionen Euro
nochmal für das nationale
Raumfahrtprogramm auf dem Weg gebracht
auch hier mit einem Baustein für
kleinstsatelliten für kleinsträger für
resiliente Kommunikation in einen
Wettbewerb der da ausgeschrieben werden
soll man sieht wir arbeiten sehr gut
miteinander wir kombinieren europäische
und deutsche Raumfahrt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen neben
einer aktiven Wirtschaftspolitik macht
natürlich das Wirtschaft und
klimaministerium oder muss das
Wirtschaft und Ministerium auch noch
eine koordinierte Klimapolitik machen da
haben sie Herr Minister leider nicht die
besten Voraussetzungen ihres Vorgängers
übernommen die Bundesrechnungshof
Berichte zu Energiewende sind
hinlänglich bekannt wenig Steuerung
wenig Koordination wenig Wirksamkeit
dass die Union jetzt im Zuge der
Klimakonferenz auch noch die
internationalen klimaschutzmittel
streichen wollte das sollte ja auf jeden
Fall mal erwähnt werden finde ich
bemerkenswert aber ich glaube wichtig
ist dass wir auch Aufgaben haben wir
haben einen Energie- und Klima vor einem
klimatransformation vor mit 104
Milliarden Euro schönen Gruß an Fridays
for future ihre Forderung ist längst
erfüllt wir haben 4,2 Milliarden Euro
für den internationalen Klimaschutz das
Versprechen von Angela Merkel ist auch
erfüllt aber in Wahrheit wissen wir
nicht genau was mit diesen vielen
Instrumenten die im Haushalt haben am
Ende erzielt wird die Wirksamkeit muss
noch verbessert werden deshalb ist es
gut dass wir jetzt Beschlüsse gefasst
haben dass das dass das Monitoring dass
die Berichte verbessert werden sowohl
beim
klima-iki beim internationalen
Klimaschutz das ist uns gelungen und
deshalb werden wir in der nächsten Zeit
auch dafür sorgen dass es ein
koordinierten und wirksamen Klimaschutz
in Deutschland gibt vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit Karsten klein aus der
FDP-Fraktion in der Debatte über den
Einzelplan 09 Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz
gut dass sie noch dabei sind denn jetzt
kommt als nächstes Mal Jens Spahn aber
es kommt das Ergebnis zum
bürgergeldgesetz
Beschlussempfehlung des
Vermittlungsausschusses zu dem 12 Gesetz
zur Änderung des zweiten Buches
Sozialgesetzbuch und anderer Gesetze
Einführung eines Bürgergeldes auf den
Drucksachen
3873 4.226
4360 und 4.600 abgegebene Stimmkarten
657 mit ja haben gestimmt
557 mit Nein 98 Enthaltungen 2 damit ist
die Beschlussempfehlung angenommen
und zwar mit einer überdeutlichen
Mehrheit und da der Bundestag jetzt ja
gesagt hat zum bürgergeldgesetz kannten
sich auch der Bundesrat damit befassen
dass wir dann in den nächsten Minuten
passieren wir werden Ihnen das
nachliefern sobald die haushaltswoche
des Bundestages zum Ende gekommen ist
und jetzt noch mal zu dem was ich eben
sagen wollte gut dass sie noch dabei
sind jetzt Jens Spahn stellvertretender
Vorsitzender der Unionsfraktion und
danach der zuständige Minister Robert
Habeck viele Menschen beginnen zu heizen
in ihren privaten Haushalten in den
Büros in den Unternehmen das Problem ist
nur viele müssen jetzt anfangen zu
heizen ohne wirklich zu wissen ob sie es
sich leisten können zum ersten ersten
das passiert gerade dieser Tage werden
viele Strom und Gaspreise erhöht die
Menschen erhalten die entsprechenden
Rechnung und die Wochen die Monate
vergehen es gab koalitionsausschüsse mit
entsprechenden Einigungen zumindest
scheinbar es gab die konzertierte Aktion
hat man auch schon lange nichts mehr von
gehört die Kommission hat mittlerweile
vor sechs sieben Wochen erste Vorschläge
vorgelegt es gibt jetzt einen ersten
Gesetzentwurf nach ersten Lesen muss man
sagen danach ist noch weniger klar als
vorher klar war es geht sie an sind sie
sind Wochen und monatelang sie sind
Wochen und monatelang im Sommer gegen
die Wand angelaufen bei der gasumlage
haben Zeit vertrödelt jetzt hängt der
Winter an und die Menschen wissen immer
noch nicht was für sie gilt und das ist
ein Problem in diesen Zeiten
wir haben ja diese Woche sind wir ja
hier schon literarisch geworden aber
Stadt bei Louis Carroll hätte man besser
bei
Samuel Beckett nachgeschaut warten auf
Godo das ist es doch eher was hier
zutrifft wenn wenn Unruhe ist im Land
wenn es Montagsdemonstrationen gibt wenn
Menschen den Glauben an die Politik
verlieren dann hat das mit manchen zu
tun es hat aber vor allem mit einem zu
tun dass diese Bundesregierung auch so
viele Monate nach Kriegsbeginn auch
nachdem so viel Zeit hier eigentlich
vergangen ist so klar war dass dieser
Winter kommt und wo viele unsicher sind
bei den Gas und Strompreisen wenn jemand
Verantwortung hat für die Unruhe und
Unsicherheit im Land dann eine
Bundesregierung die nicht entscheidet wo
Entscheidung dringend notwendig werden
die wenigen Male wo sie konsequent
pragmatisch gewesen sind in den letzten
Monaten da waren sie erfolgreich das
muss man auch anerkennen das war richtig
bei den lng-terminals die Beschleunigung
das war gut das war richtig es ist
gelungen die Gasspeicher zu füllen auch
das ist gut für den Winter aber da haben
sie eben alles beiseite gelassen was sie
bisher als Parteiprogramm Artikel hatten
was sie bisher gesagt haben haben
geschaut auf das was notwendig ist und
haben es getan aber damit aber damit
aber damit soll ich ihn zum Erbe von
Peter Altmaier kann ich Ihnen was sagen
ich war nämlich dabei ja ja warten Sie
mal ab es war der Finanzminister Olaf
Scholz der ja wie wir gemerkt haben
schon vergessen hat dass er reagiert hat
es war der Finanzminister Olaf Scholz
der den Bau von lng-terminal zum
US-amerikanisches Gas nach Deutschland
zu bringen davon abhängig gemacht hat
dass die USA die Sanktionen gegen Nord
Stream 2 aufheben es war Olaf Scholz wir
haben am Ende den Russen entgegen
gekommen ist und in Amerikanern nicht
sicher Germanist bauen wollte das war
nämlich die Geschichte insofern sollten
Sie
öfter mal genau hinschauen was gewesen
ist da wo sie konsequent pragmatisch
waren waren sie erfolgreich da wo sie
nicht pragmatisch waren sehen wir
halbherzige Entscheidung nehmen Sie nur
die Kernenergie in der Debatte hier dazu
hat ein grüner Kollege gesagt es wäre
eine Zumutung diese Entscheidung treffen
zu müssen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die eigentliche Zumutung ist woanders
wir haben Bürgerinnen und Bürger die
sich den Strom nicht leisten können
jeder weiß es ist Angebots Knappheit
Preise gehen darunter oder das Angebot
breiter wird und auch verlässlich und
der nächste der übernächste Winter das
sagen auch alle Expertinnen und Experten
wird härter im Zweifel noch als dieser
und deswegen haben sie sich irgendwie
hingewürgt um 12 Wochen die Laufzeit
wohl zu verlängern wo zwei Jahre
notwendig gewesen sind die Zumutung die
war nicht bei den Grünen die Zumutung
ist für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger eine
zu sehen wie sie sich zu den notwendigen
Entscheidungen
und deswegen scären auch so viel mehr zu
sagen will ich eines aber noch
grundsätzlich sagen zur Art der Debatte
weil wenn man das mal aufmerksam
verfolgt diese Woche dann stimme ich zu
ja in Zeiten wie diesen in Zeiten von
nationaler Krise brauchte es
Zusammenhalt und ja es geht auch um die
Art der Debatte aber um Einigkeit um
Einigkeit muss man sich auch bemühen und
wenn gelegentlich der Blick geworfen
wird auf die Krise vorher in der
Pandemie war Einigkeit in der
Bundesregierung über den Kurs da gab es
keine Debatte wir erleben hier das
Wirtschafts- und Finanzminister jeden
Tag miteinander streiten darüber was der
richtige Kurs ist in der Krise vorher
war Einigkeit mit den Ländern und den
Kommunen wir haben darüber herum
gerungen stundenlang um einig zu sein
mit Ländern und Kommunen sie haben es
geschafft unabhängig von der Farbenlehre
alle Länder gegen sich aufzubringen
innerhalb weniger Wochen auch das ist in
dieser Krise eine Entlastung um eben
Zusammenhalt herzustellen aber das
allerentscheidende ist die Frage des
Umgangs mit Kritik und wir haben das ja
gerade schon wieder erlebt in der
Debatte zum Bürgergeld Zusammenhalt
entsteht nicht durch das Beschwören der
eigenen Großartigkeit Geschlossenheit
entsteht nicht durch Gehorsam gemeinsam
nicht gemein sind nicht durch
gegenseitiges verächtlich machen
Zusammenhalt entsteht durch gute
Debatten um das Regeln durch um eine
richtige Lösung da wo sie da wo sie das
Gute Argument haben da wo sie das
bessere Argument haben sind wir ihnen
gefolgt aber Sie müssen es aushalten
denn es ist das Elexier einer Demokratie
und es ist die Voraussetzung für
Zusammenhalt das Gute Debatten auch
strittige Debatten geführt werden da wo
sie richtig liegen werden wir ihnen
zustimmen aber da muss ich falsch liegen
wo sie halbherzig agieren wo sie zögern
da wird es auch in Zukunft Kritik geben
gewöhnen sie sich daran
nächster Redner für die Bundesregierung
der Bundesminister dr Robert Habeck
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren bevor ich zum Haushalt komme
lassen Sie mich auf einige der reden
kurz noch eingehen ohne ist zu lang
machen zu wollen dennoch würde ich gerne
dass die Behauptung der AFD nicht
unkommentiert im Raum stehen bleiben sie
haben von deutschen Interessen
gesprochen und dass sie gewahrt werden
sollen ich sage Ihnen das wichtigste
deutsche Interesse ist das Kriegsfürsten
nicht nach guteren Art andere Länder
überfallen dürfen dass ich diese Politik
in Europa nicht durchsetzt und wo ich
dabei bin
es ist nicht im deutschen Interesse das
im Stil von Russia Today hier Ursache
und Wirkung verdreht wird das ist nicht
im deutschen Interesse
dazu gehört auch
sie haben gesagt wir sollen die Ursachen
für diese Krise stoppen genau darum geht
es die Ursache für diese Krise zu
stoppen heißt Putin in den Arm zu fallen
und zu verhindern dass er sich
durchsetzt Sanktionen sind ein
notwendiges Mittel dazu genau das zu tun
und ich glaube auch dass der Weg
erfolgreich ist der Krieg in der Ukraine
ist sicherlich kein
Vorbild für andere Länder es ist ein
Desaster auf dem Schlachtfeld und es ist
ein Desaster für die russische Ökonomie
das nicht zu sehen heißt dass man
politisch blind ist sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren
damit würde ich zum Haushalt kommen und
kurz auf den Kollegen Mattfeld eingehen
lieber Andreas Martin zugehört habe habe
ich mich schon gefragt ob sie den
Haushalt gelesen haben es waren schon
eine sehr
paralleluniversumslastige Rede die sie
hier gehalten haben sie haben gesagt wir
tun zu wenig für den Mittelstand das
Mittelstandsprogramm Zimmer ist auf 700
Millionen Euro aufgestockt worden sie
haben gesagt wir konzentrieren uns nur
auf Klima die haben übersehen dass wir
von der Gesundheitswirtschaft über die
Digitalisierung über die
Cloud-Infrastruktur und über die
Raumfahrt große Programm Volumina
stemmen und die deutsche Wirtschaft in
allen Bereichen für die Zukunft fit zu
machen und zu unterstützen
und wo ich dabei bin
Klima ist die Zukunft oder Klimaschutz
eine klimaneutrale CO2-arme
Produktionsweise und konsumweise ist die
ökonomische Zukunft es ist die
ökonomische Zukunft und wenn sie uns
schon nicht glauben möchte ich als
Beispiel den American Inflation
reduction Act vor anführen der ja die
gesamte Feuerkraft der amerikanischen
Finanzmöglichkeiten auf
klimaanteiltechnologien konzentriert was
die machen ist exakt das was der Klima
und Transformation ebenfalls auch macht
nämlich die Förderung von erneuerbaren
Energien von Förderung von Wasserstoff
die Förderung von Batterien die
Förderung von Immobilität all das ist
der Inflation redakt die Amerikaner
haben sich also entschieden den
Leitmarkt den Kampf um den Leitmarkt
erneuerbare Leitmarkt zukünftige
Industrie zu führen allerdings ist damit
auch die Entscheidung getroffen wo der
leitenmarkt sein wird es wird ein
Wettbewerb zwischen den großen
ökonomischen Mächten geben wer am
stärksten am schnellsten am
entschiedensten diesen Leitmarkt einer
klimaneutralen einer grünen Industrie
aufbaut zu sagen das ist alles nur
ökokrams oder Klimaschutz verkennt die
ökonomische Auseinandersetzung in der
wir uns befinden die Zukunft wird
darüber entschieden wer am schnellsten
und am besten
Innovationskraft und Leistungsfähigkeit
in einem Bereich einer grünen Wirtschaft
aufbaut sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
wir haben ein rekordinflation wir haben
eine drohende Rezession wir haben
Energieknappheit wir haben Krieg in
Europa wir haben einen Wandel und das
ist die hüftliche Formulierung im
globalen Wettbewerb eigentlich muss man
sagen es ist eine immer stärkere
konfliktreichere Geopolitik die
zurückkommt wir haben die Klimakrise mit
enormen auch ökonomischen Folgen über
alle anderen will ich hier gar nicht
reden über das Elend der Menschen ich
habe als ich in Singapur war mit dem
Wirtschaftsminister aus Pakistan mich
getroffen
die wirtschaftsbeziehung zu Pakistan
sicherlich ausbaufähig aber was er
geschildert hat über das Sterben in
Pakistan wegen grassierender
Klimaveränderung und es waren seine
Worte Klimaveränderung das hat einfach
mal ein ganz anderes Bild darauf gegeben
wir haben Rohstoffmangel sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren die Herausforderung für
denen dieses Land steht sie könnten
nicht größer sein
es bedarf einer enormen Kraftanstrengung
und diese Herausforderung zu stehen und
zu stemmen politisch wie
gesellschaftlich und der Haushalt des
Einzelplans 09 bildet diese
Kraftanstrengung ab die Gelder steigen
noch einmal der Haushalt umfasst
insgesamt 14,9 Milliarden Euro das sind
3,2 Milliarden mehr als der Haushalt 22
und wenn man sich anschaut wo worauf
sich diese Gelder konzentrieren dann
sieht man ziemlich genau die Strategie
der Bundesregierung kurzfristige
Sicherung in der Krise der eine
Schwerpunkt das sind die Investitionen
in Betrieb und Aufbau Schiffe Ersatz zu
schaffen für das russische Gas das ja
schon nicht gekommen ist ja es war Putin
der das Gas abgedreht hat so viel zu
Nord Stream
sie haben offensichtlich zu viel Wasser
today geguckt sie müssen doch wohl
anerkennen sie müssen die Fakten
anerkennen dass das Gas aus Russland
nicht kam es gibt keine Sanktionen gegen
Gas zweitens Sicherung einer
Ölversorgung für Schwedt
pipeline-systeme aufzubauen als
Alternative zu der druckpipeline all das
spiegelt sich in dem Haushalt wieder und
kostet natürlich ziemlich viel Geld und
dann aber auch
dann aber auch die Konzentration auf die
Zukunftsaufgaben ich habe sie eben schon
erwähnt von der Cloud-Technologie zu
Unterstützung einer digitalen Wirtschaft
bisschen zu den
Investitionsprogrammen für den
Mittelstand im Bereich der Erneuerbaren
der eine Erneuerbaren Wirtschaft sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren der Einzelplan
60 ist der Einzelplan der das den
klimatransformationsformen beherbergt
der umfasst für das nächste Jahr 36
Milliarden Euro ich will damit sagen
dass die Summen die wir mobilisieren
durchaus erheblich sind und die Summen
sind mit den amerikanischen Ausgaben
durchaus wettbewerbsfähig die 400
Milliarden Euro die dort erstmal bereit
stehen wir haben über einen groben
geschätzt 200 Milliarden alleine in
Deutschland im Klima und Transformation
das ist durchaus vergleichbar die
Aufgabe ist dass wir schneller und
entschiedener werden müssen bei Planung
für Ausgaben und bei dem
Wettbewerbsrecht innerhalb von Europa
das heißt wir müssen entschiedener und
entschlossener werden nicht zögerlicher
und in Frage stellen was wir eigentlich
auch mit Verlaub in diesem Haus schon
erkannt haben denn den
klimakransformationsfonds den haben wir
geerbt insofern das was eigentlich am
hinderlichsten ist bei einer
entschiedenen Wirtschaftspolitik ist der
permanente intellektuelle Rückfall auch
in die Jahre wo wir eigentlich schon mal
weiter waren sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren wir werden den Klima und
Transformation von nutzen um exakt
entlang dieser Strategie die nächsten
Schritte zu gehen wir sind gerade dabei
die Richtlinie für die sogenannten
Karben Kontakte Ford differences zu
Design sie ist fertig sie befindet sich
jetzt in der Abstimmung mit den anderen
Häuser wir werden anderen Häusern wir
werden also im nächsten Jahr Verträge
für die Industrie anbieten die dann die
dekarbonisierung den Weg hin zu einer
Wasserstofftechnologie beschreiten wird
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
abschließend
wir sind mitten in einer Krise der Druck
auf die Wirtschaft und auf die
Bevölkerung ist enorm hoch wir kämpfen
uns aber und ich glaube das letzte Jahr
hat gezeigt dass wir das durchaus in der
Lage sind zu tun wir kämpfen uns aber
erfolgreich Schritt für Schritt aus
dieser Krise raus das nächste Jahr wird
nicht weniger hart werden der Haushalt
allerdings gibt uns die Möglichkeit
dafür die nächsten Schritte Zug Umzug zu
gehen und so diese Zeit zu überstehen um
danach in die richtigen Moment
reinzukommen und die Wertschöpfung die
Wirtschaft die Prosperität in
Deutschland hochzuhalten danke schön
der Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck der ja bekanntermaßen auch für
Klimaschutz zuständig ist in der Debatte
über seinen Etat für das Jahr
2023 etwas 14 einhalb Milliarden Euro
hat er zur Verfügung um seine
politischen Ziele durchzusetzen live
ericon ist der nächste Redner
stellvertretender Vorsitzender
afd-fraktion heute in einem Monat ist
Weihnachten dann soll der
Weihnachtsbraten auf dem Tisch stehen
aber viele werden in diesem Jahr wohl
darauf verzichten eine Weihnachtsgans
kostet mittlerweile an die 100 €. die
massive teurerung frisst sich immer
tiefer in unsere Portemonnaies über 10%
Inflation bei Lebensmitteln über 20%
Inflation und viele Produzenten haben
gerade erst ein Drittel der gestiegene
Produktionskosten an die Kunden
weitergegeben es kommt also wohl noch
dicker hier wird unseren Bürgern der
Wohlstand gestohlen mit dieser Inflation
und bedanken dürfen sich die Menschen
dafür bei Ihnen auch bei Ihnen Herr
Minister und bei ihren Vorgängern die
die dümmste Energiepolitik der Welt
betreiben wegen der explodierenden
Energiepreise verlassen große
Unternehmen unser Land oder spielen
zumindest jetzt schon mit dem Gedanken
eine Insolvenzwelle ist bereits
angerollt die reden jetzt ernsthaft über
die Deindustrialisierung unseres Landes
das hätten wir uns doch vor Wochen gar
nicht vorstellen können aber selbst in
dieser dramatischen Krise haben sie
nicht den Mum zuzugeben was
offensichtlich ist ihre sogenannte
Energiewende ist krachend gescheitert
ich hatte vor einigen Wochen ein sehr
langes hörte zu ergriffen ein sehr
langes und ausführliches Gespräch mit
einem Unternehmen das sehr betroffen ist
mit Karla mit dem Porzellanhersteller
aus Thüringen der Geschäftsführer hat
mir die Zahlen seines Unternehmens
gezeigt und er wusste nicht wie es
weitergehen soll sein Gasversorger hat
ihm gekündigt weil auch der keine Ahnung
hat wie es weitergehen soll und jetzt
war das einzige Angebot dass er auf
Basis von Spotmarkt Preisen ein Angebot
bekommen sollte was natürlich absolut
unmöglich ist weil ein Unternehmen
planen muss und stand gestern hat Carla
immer noch keinen passenden Gasvertrag
das ist die Lage in tausenden
Unternehmen in Deutschland und sie
ändern daran bisher überhaupt nicht
wann kommen sie endlich aus dem Knick
mit Gas strompreisbremse und wann
kümmern sie sich um die Ausweitung des
energieangebots sind das ist wirklich
Ursachenbekämpfung die wir brauchen wir
brauchen ausreichend Gas china
hat sich gestern in Mengen in rauen
Mengen Gas besorgt in Katar Herr
Minister sie waren da sie haben tief
gebuckelt vor den Scheiß es kam aber
nichts dabei heraus die Chinesen haben
sich langfristig gebunden und haben
ihren Vertrag gemacht wie die Italiener
schon zuvor sie bekommen es nicht auf
die Reise sie wollen es nicht auf die
Reihe bekommen das ist wirklich blanker
deliktatismus in diesem
Wirtschaftsministerium
für uns bleibt dort nichts mehr übrig
aber wie wollen sie die Speicher füllen
im nächsten Jahr wie wollen sie es denn
machen
sie haben noch eine Chance sie haben
noch eine Chance für brauchen den
funktionierenden Strang von nordstream 2
der ist notwendig wenn wir im nächsten
Jahr unsere Gasspeicher wieder füllen
wollen anders wird es nicht
funktionieren
meine Damen und Herren
es ist geboten jetzt zu handeln wir sind
im dramatischen Zeiten und Herr Minister
ein guter Krisenmanager hätte jetzt gar
keine Zeit mehr teure Haus und Hof
Fotografen zu engagieren oder vom
heroischen Tragen der One Love Armbinde
zu träumen dazu sind unsere Probleme
viel zu existenziell was wir jetzt
brauchen ist endlich ein Handeln für
sichere und bezahlbare Energie damit
unser Land leben kann herzlichen Dank
der Bundestag diskutiert über den Etat
des Bundeswirtschaftsministers und Ihnen
als aufmerksame Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer ist es ja vorhin schon mal
aufgefallen ich habe es auch schon mal
erklärt für alle die ein bisschen später
eingeschaltet haben ziemlich viel orange
heute in den Rhein der Abgeordneten es
ist nämlich internationaler Tag gegen
die Gewalt gegen Frauen immer am 25
November und orange
er symbolisiert die Zukunft ohne Gewalt
gegen Frauen falls ihm aufmerksam wie
sie sind aufgefallen ist wie häufig
diese Frage hier ist Farbe heute hier im
Plenum vertreten ist es spricht Bernd
Westphal der wirtschaftspolitische
Sprecher der SPD-Fraktion
das Bundeshaushalt ist ist das gut
investiertes Geld das schafft die
Zukunft unseres Landes und Perspektiven
und das machen wir mit diesem
Bundeshaushalt
die Ampelkoalition stärkt
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt das
haben wir bewiesen eben mit dem
Beschluss zum Bürgergeld der gut ist das
ist ein guter Beschluss für unsere
gesellschaftliche Entwicklung wir
organisieren Unterstützung für private
Haushalte und Unternehmen der Abschlag
im Dezember ist genau das was wir jetzt
kurzfristig wirksam auf den Weg bringen
und die anderen Dinge werden doch in
dieser diesen Sitzungswochen vor
Weihnachten auf den Weg gebracht genau
diese Komplexität dieser Sachen braucht
eben auch diese Zeit damit es gelingt
wir werden aber auch sehr positive
Impulse für Investitionen in den
Unternehmen setzen und vor allen Dingen
die Modernisierung der Infrastruktur
nach vorne bringen
gerade was den Bereich der Fachkräfte
Sicherung angeht gibt es eine
Verstärkung der aus- und Weiterbildung
gerade auch für den Bereich des
Handwerks wo dringend Fachkräfte gesucht
werden werden die
Ausbildungsmöglichkeiten finanziell
unterstützt wir werden eine Absicherung
der Forschung und Entwicklungsaufgaben
gerade mit dem mittelaufwuchs in der
Industrieforschung aber auch in dem
Bereich Zimt das Programm was sehr
innovativ in den letzten Jahrzehnten
etabliert ist sind Mittel nochmal
zugeflossen gerade der Mittelstand wird
hier eine Innovationsförderung bekommen
die eben auch stärken und auch die
Sicherung der Kaufkraft wird nicht nur
durch das Bürgergeld sondern auch mit
der Stärkung von der Mindestlohn von
Renten von Kindergeld und anderen Dingen
und auch die Option die klug war 3000 €
Steuer und abgabenfrei als Instrument zu
etablieren werden die Tarifpartner
aufnehmen das schafft Kaufkraft und
stärkt unsere Wirtschaft meine Damen und
Herren
auch
zukunftsweisende Branchen wie zum
Beispiel die Gesundheitswirtschaft mit
dem ipsafe was wir haben also ein
besonderes
Investitionsvolumen für die
Gesundheitswirtschaft wird genau dieses
innovative Umfeld schaffen was wir
benötigen und auch die Luft und
Raumfahrt dort sind wir Motor der
europäischen Raumfahrt etwas was wir
wirklich mit Inhalten noch mal erfüllen
ersparen das sind Inhalte das sind
konkrete Dinge aus dem Bundeshaushalt
was sie in fünf Minuten hier geschafft
haben aber nur Kritik nicht ein
inhaltlicher Punkt aus der Union sie
machen das noch nicht so lange
vielleicht kommt ja da auch noch was
die US-Regierung will mit dem Inflation
mit will ihre Inflation mit einem
Milliarden Subventionsprogramm bekämpfen
im sogenannten Inflation reduction Act
dieses Milliardensubventionen sind
enorme Steuervorteile in den USA und sie
werden natürlich auch Einfluss haben auf
Investitionsentscheidung der Unternehmen
hier in Deutschland und deshalb brauchen
wir eine Antwort darauf Herr
Bundeswirtschaftsminister wir müssen
darüber nachdenken wie wir darauf
reagieren nächste Woche ist EU-Kommissar
Beton hier in Berlin wir haben
Gelegenheit im Wirtschaftsausschuss mit
ihm darüber zu diskutieren und ich finde
dass wir mit den Instrumenten auch
darüber nachdenken müssen mit einem zum
Beispiel etablierten industriestrompreis
die Basis für industrielle Produktion in
Deutschland zu sichern bessere
Abschreibungsmöglichkeiten und mit einer
klugen Standortpolitik dem was
entgegenzusetzen
im März hat am Mittwoch in seiner Rede
gesagt Zweifel und Bedenken hat die
Union wenn man sich den Haushalt anguckt
und die Politik der Ampel wirklich mal
ernsthaft bewertet komme ich zu ganz
anderen Ergebnissen die
Regierungskoalition modernisiert unser
Land sie spannt Schutzschirme auf zur
Überwindung der Krise sorgt für gute
investitions- und Standortbedingungen
schafft Perspektiven für alle Menschen
in unserem Land und sorgt für den
Zusammenhalt in dieser Gesellschaft das
sind alles gute Gründe zuversichtlich zu
sein herzlichen Dank und Glück auf
nächster Redner für die Fraktion DIE
LINKE Ralf lenkert
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen fast 40 Cent
kostet da eine Kilowattstunde Strom an
der Börse genau vor einem Jahr da gab es
noch kein Krieg gegen die Ukraine heute
sind es zehn Cent weniger
im juni 2019 stand Deutschland dreimal
kurz vor einem Blackout schuld war nicht
die erneuerbaren Energien Verursacher
waren jeweils Spekulanten an der Börse
die Linke lehnt Börsenspekulation ab
weil sie uns gefährdet
was vielleicht den ein oder anderen
irritiert wir sind auch für Wohlstand
für alle aber wir sind dagegen dass
einige wenige den Wohlstand für sich
beanspruchen und dadurch die Mehrheit
der Menschen verarmt
und die Börse ist ein Instrument mit dem
bei Naturkatastrophen bei kriegen oder
durch Marktmanipulation der Wohlstand
der Mehrheit zerstört wird und die
Bundesregierung sie sieht zu sie schnürt
unzureichenden entlastungspakete statt
auf die geniale Idee zu setzen
Spekulationsgewinne einzukassieren mit
einer echten übergewinnsteuerung
und mit Preiskontrollen Wucherpreise zu
beenden so schlägt es die Linke vor
und egal wie die Ampel die Bremsen nennt
es bleiben nur kosmetische Eingriffe mit
denen sie letztlich die Börse und nicht
die Menschen schützen Ihre
Milliardensubventionen
ihre Milliardensubventionen fließen
durch die Hände der Menschen in die
Taschen der Konzerne und da gegen und
immer wieder fordert DIE LINKE eine
Vergesellschaftung der Energiewirtschaft
und damit bleiben Energiekosten
bezahlbar damit wird
Versorgungssicherheit gewährleistet und
damit sichern wir letztlich eine
klimaneutrale Energiewirtschaft
und kurzfristig liebe Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern fordern wir bezahlbare
energiekontingente und monatliche
Direktzahlung an alle Haushalte von 75
Euro je Haushalt plus 50 Euro je Person
in jedem Monat vielen Dank
nächster Redner für die FDP-Fraktion
Hagen Reinhold
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren debatten wie
die um cosco in den letzten Wochen
zeigen das endlich in der Regierung
durch die Regierung auch erst recht
durch das Wirtschaftsministerium aber
auch in der Bevölkerung in der
Wirtschaft eine wichtige Debatte
begonnen hat eine Debatte um
strategische Abhängigkeiten um
rohstoffsicherheit um die Verfügbarkeit
von Produkten aber auch um die von
strategischer Infrastruktur was ist das
eigentlich was bedeutet das für uns aber
auch darum was für Fähigkeiten es
eigentlich in einem Land braucht um in
Zukunft erfolgreich zu sein und ich bin
froh dass wir das begonnen haben und
weiterführen werden und wir erkannt
haben dass sie Sicherung von Wohlstand
und von Arbeit auch davon abhängt welche
Fähigkeiten in diesem Land verfügbar
sind und viele Antworten darauf bietet
der Haushalt des Wirtschaftsministeriums
ich nehme mal die strategische
Abhängigkeit Energie ja wir nehmen jetzt
200 Milliarden Euro in die Hand um für
kleine mittelständische Unternehmen für
die Menschen in diesem Land Energie
bezahlbar zu machen aber er steht eben
zum Beispiel auch in diesem Haushalt
drinne eine Studie zu erarbeiten wie wir
eigentlich Tanker für LNG für
Wasserstoff in der Zukunft für unser
Land sichern können warum weil wir
erkannt haben dass Länder wie Katha
nicht nur Energie besitzen sondern sich
60 Prozent der tankerbaukapazitäten
weltweit in den nächsten Jahren schon
gesichert haben und der Preis von
Energie sich eben nicht nur
zusammensetzt aus der Verfügung
Verfügbarkeit von Energie sondern auch
dem Transport und deshalb Herr Mattfeld
kann ich gar nicht verstehen dass sie
sagen die Ampel reagiert viel zu spät
und auch noch falsch denn gucken wir uns
die Vergangenheit an da ist zu wenig
geschehen worden passiert in diesem Land
diese Fähigkeiten in Deutschland zu
erhalten ich erinnere daran wie uns die
solange Branche abhanden gekommen ist
ich erinnere daran wie die Windkraft
gelitten hat in diesem Land wenn weitere
Fähigkeiten in dem Land abhanden kommt
dann werden wir Wohlstand und Zukunft
und arbeitet in diesem Land nicht sicher
darauf gibt dieser Bundeshaushalt
deutlicher Antworten
wir werden die Energiesicherheit in
Deutschland gewährleisten indem wir
Energie umstellen auch das braucht
Fähigkeiten unter anderem in der
maritimen Industrie wir brauchen
Errichter Schiffe vor offshore
Windkraftanlagen kabelverlegeschiffe und
so weiter und deshalb ist es wichtig
dass nicht nur die Politik die kann es
nicht alleine richten sondern auch
Wirtschaft und Bevölkerung erkannt haben
das kostet auch was und ich muss was
dafür tun die Bundesregierung die
öffentliche Hand muss erkennen dass es
wichtig ist in Europa in Deutschland
Industrie zu stärken indem ich Produkte
hier Abfrage und nicht in Asien kaufe
Gott sei Dank haben wir eine Debatte um
eine neue china-strategie die uns zeigt
wie die Abhängigkeit zu Asien ist aber
auch die Wirtschaft muss erkennen dass
es wichtig ist in Europa in Deutschland
Fähigkeiten vorzuhalten und dabei
unterstützen wir Sie bei der Maritim
Wirtschaft z.B in diesem Jahr 2003 im
nächsten Jahr 2023 62 Millionen Euro
über 50 Milliarden mehr Millionen mehr
für Verpflichtungsermächtigung 24 bis 27
um Forschung und Verbindung
voranzutreiben und Fähigkeiten in
Deutschland zu erhalten die es dringend
braucht Wohlstand und Arbeit in diesem
Land zu sichern die letzten Worte will
ich für die energieturnals aufbringen
weil auch das Lob von der CDU
wahrgenommen es einen Unterschied macht
wie wir das energy Beschleunigungsgesetz
angebaut aufgesetzt haben sie haben
versucht planungsbeschleunigung per
Gesetzeskraft bei einzelnen Vorhaben
durchzusetzen wir haben die Bürokratie
abgebaut wonach die Wirtschaft seit
Jahren schreit weil wir nämlich die
Verfahren vereinfacht haben im
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfungsverfahren
wir haben nur eine Rechtsinstanz bis zur
Sicherheit geschaffen das ist eine
Bürokratisierung die wir geschaffen
haben und nicht wie sie die letzten
Jahre per Gesetzeskraft verordnet
welches Infrastrukturprojekt entsteht
das macht den Unterschied zu dieser
Ampel wir entbürokratisieren und
schaffen Zukunft sie haben es anders
probiert das hat nicht funktioniert
deshalb ist diese fortschrittskoalition
genau die Richtige für dieses Land
der Bundestag debattiert über den
Einzelplan 09 Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz
nächster Redner Andreas junger
parteivorsitzer cdu/csu und Klima und
energie-koalitionsvertrag zum Beispiel
bei einigen
schienenverkehrsprojekten oder aber so
wie sie es bei den lng-terminals
angegangen wurde wir freuen uns darüber
dass es so schnell gegangen ist aber ich
sage Ihnen dann auch machen sie es doch
jetzt auch bei den anderen Dingen machen
sie es bei den erneuerbaren Energien
machen sie es bei den Stromtrassen
machen sie es bei der Wasserstoff
Infrastruktur machen sich bei der
Verkehrsinfrastruktur Deutschland muss
insgesamt schneller werden deshalb muss
dieses Verfahren mit Stil bilden werden
wenn sie das so aufgreifen unsere
Unterstützung haben wir dafür wir
fordern das Hier und Heute
und dann Herrn Kollege Junge von der SPD
wenn Sie unsere Arbeit hier als
Seitenlinie bezeichnet als Seitenlinie
sagt es wenig aus über die Union aber
viel über ihr grundlegend falsches
Verständnis von parlamentarischer
Demokratie ja ja
ihr Parteifreund Franz münteferien der
sagt die Opposition ist mist ich sage
Ihnen Mist ist Biomasse aus Biomasse
kann man was Gutes machen zum Beispiel
neue Energie und in diesem Geiste gehen
wir unsere Arbeit hier an in diesem
Geiste machen wir eine konstruktive
Oppositionsarbeit und das will ich Ihnen
ein paar Beispielen verdeutlichen beim
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien beim
osterpaket der Minister habe weg da
haben wir nichts hier vorgeschlagen was
irgendwas gebremstätig wir haben nur
Vorschläge gemacht die will beschleunigt
hätten sie haben abgelehnt zweimal
unseren Vorschlag Steuerfreiheit für
private PV-Anlagen zweimal abgelehnt
werden drittes Mal beantragt dann haben
sie es übernommen und ist ein richtiger
Schritt und deshalb ermuntere ich sie
sie haben ist zweimal abgelegt abgelehnt
und unseren Antrag die
Registrierungspflicht für PV-Anlagen in
dieser Krise auszusetzen die muss
ausgesetzt werden der liegen überall im
Land große PV-Anlagen sagt die könnten
jetzt ans Netz gehen aber die werden
nicht angeschlossen weil sie nicht
bereit sind auf die Regierung
Registrierungspflicht sie verzichten
Herr Herbig ich kann mir nicht ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass sie das für
richtig halten ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass es für richtig halten
das in dieser Krise Sonnenenergie die
eingesetzt werden könnte nicht
eingesetzt wird weil sie diesen Antrag
ablehnen wir werden in der nächsten
Sitzungswoche ein drittes Mal stellen es
wäre klug wenn sie es noch mal angucken
wir werden darauf drängen wir brauchen
nicht alle Möglichkeiten der
Energieerzeugung gerade auch das was auf
unserem TV
anderen mit unserem tv-anlagen möglich
ist dann haben Sie jetzt ein Vorschlag
vorgelegt zu auch rückwirkenden
Abschöpfung von Erträgen bei den
erneuerbaren Energien Herr Minister was
sie hier vorgelegt haben ist eine
Erneuerbaren Bremse der Tod ein
Kollateralschaden für die Energiewende
es werden schon jetzt Investitionen
zurückgestellt und übrigens weil über
den Standort gesprochen wurde und hier
gesagt wurde entstand dort würde
schlecht geredet nicht wegen
Redebeiträgen aus der Opposition sondern
wegen dieser Ankündigung aus der
Bundesregierung werden jetzt
Investitionen im TV im Windkraft
zurückgestellt die Bioenergie soll neu
gedeckelt werden nehmen Sie diese Pläne
zurück der Minister die Wortwahl wird
Ihnen vielleicht nicht gefallen aber
machen Sie es wie bei der gasumlage
diese Erneuerbaren Bremse muss weg
weil es darum geht ich habe den beraten
Sie es doch mal dann beraten Sie es doch
mal das das ist doch jetzt in der Region
hier vorgeschlagen worden ich nehme wahr
Kritik aus der SPD an dem Vorschlag der
Regierung nehmen Sie es zurück das
beschädigte Energiewende müssen sie auch
beschleunigen und es muss man sich mal
genau angucken deswegen ist rückwirkend
eingegriffen werden rückwirkend
Rückwirkung ist abwirkung des
beschädigtes Vertrauen in solche
Investitionen es soll nicht etwa
tatsächliche Gewinne sondern vermutete
Erträge abgeschöpft werden es gibt jetzt
namhafte Juristen die sagen das ist
vermutlich verfassungswidrig
eu-rechtswidrig es ist aber vor allem
politisch verrückt und deshalb muss es
geändert werden wir brauchen jetzt doch
gerade eine Grundlage für den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien die Steinkohle
wird völlig ausgenommen und die
Bioenergie soll neu gedeckelt werden die
muss da raus müssen doch jetzt in dieser
Krise alle Möglichkeiten gerade der
Bioenergie nutzen und deshalb ändern Sie
diese Pläne wir darauf wir brauchen
jetzt die Grundlage für den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien
und der Bundeskanzler hat dazu etwas
entlaufen des gesagt in seiner Rede in
dieser Woche hat gesagt die Zukunft der
Energieversorgung das ist Wind Sonne und
grüner Wasserstoff
den zweiten Satz also nicht dazu gesagt
aber der spiegelt sich in ihrer Politik
wieder eben nicht Bioenergie eben nicht
Geothermie im nicht die Wasserkraft und
wir trinken darauf dass das alles in der
ganzen Breite gemacht und dass die
wasserstoffstrategie nicht verschoben
wird wie durch ihre Entscheidung der
Ampel in dieser Woche ein Jahr mit dem
Bericht zur Wasserstoff Infrastruktur
verschoben statt die Dinge jetzt zu
beschleunigen zu negativen Emissionen
haben sie Einsatz im Koalitionsvertrag
aber keine einzige Initiative und mit
CCS mit ccco mit Abscheidung von
kohlendio zieht die Weichen zu stellen
dass wir Klima Neutralität mit Reduktion
der Emission und mit Abstand gemeinsam
erreichen bis 2045 das ist ihre Aufgabe
entsprechen sie den Vorgaben aus dem
Klimaschutzgesetz statt es aufzuweichen
legen Sie Ihre Programme vor legen Sie
die Initiativen vor mir dringend darauf
der Wirtschaftsminister lässt sich durch
diese Rede nicht provozieren liest
weiter vor sich hin nächste Rednerin in
der Debatte ist Katrin Uhlig für Bündnis
90 die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren wir alle wissen
wie ernst die aktuelle Lage im
Energiebereich ist wir müssen neben
Maßnahmen zur Absicherung der
Versorgungssicherheit und zur
Abmilderung der Energiekrise parallel
aber auch weiterhin alles dafür tun
unsere Energieversorgung und unsere
Wirtschaft klimaneutral auszurichten
erneuerbare Energien schützen nicht nur
unser Klima sie machen uns auch
unabhängig von fossilen Importen und
sorgen für bezahlbare Energiepreise
neben dem rechtlichen Rahmen bei dem wir
mit dem osterpaket im Sommer einen
großen Schritt nach vorne gemacht haben
ist es deshalb wichtig auch mit diesem
Haushalt die richtigen Weichen zu
stellen ich freue mich deshalb sehr das
ist im parlamentarischen Verfahren
gelungen ist den Bereich Klima und
Energie nochmal zu stärken denn in
diesem Wandel liegt doch eine Chance
eine Chance für unsere Wirtschaft für
unsere Industrie für uns alle
eine Chance für mehr Wertschöpfung und
neue Märkte eine Chance für bezahlbare
Energiepreise durch erneuerbare Energien
und Energieeffizienz eine Chance uns
unabhängiger zu machen von fossilen
Importen und unser Klima zu schützen
so wird die Energiewende die Grundlage
ist für den Wandel in der Wirtschaft so
gibt es im Handwerk und bei den KMU's
die Macher der Energiewende der Kollege
Westphal hat das eben schon angesprochen
sie bauen Solaranlagen auf Dächer
installieren klimafreundliche
Heizungssysteme und treiben den Umbau
einer klimafreundlichen Produktion voran
deshalb müssen wir dringend dem
Fachkräftemangel gerade im Handwerk
entgegenwirken und stellen deshalb
zusätzliche Mittel für ein
Qualifizierungsprogramm für die
wärmewende bereit
und um den klimafreundlichen Umbau
gerade auch bei kleinen und
Kleinstbetrieben voranzutreiben sieht
der Haushaltsentwurf nun ein neues
Förderprogramm für KMU vor das gerade
kleine Betriebe dabei unterstützen soll
ihre Produktion klimafreundlich
auszurichten
neben dem schnelleren Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren und dem klimafreundlichen
Umbau unserer Wirtschaft wird allzu oft
vergessen und Herr Jung bei ihnen in der
Rede eben auch dass wir auch in
Energieeffizienz und
Energieeinsparmaßnahmen stärken müssen
deshalb ist es richtig die dass die
Bundesregierung ein energieeffizienz-
denn gerade
Energieeffizienzmaßnahmen führen zu
Energieeinsparung und zur Optimierung
von Prozessen und bieten gleichzeitig
eine Chance für innovative Ideen und
neue Märkte auch im Haushalt haben wir
deshalb diesen zentralen Punkt für die
Energiewende aufgegriffen und flankieren
die kommenden Regelungen mit Mitteln für
Energieeffizienz Beratung sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren die aktuellen
Herausforderungen sind gerade im
Energiebereich viele dieser Haushalt ist
ein wichtiger Schritt ihnen
entgegenzutreten und unseren gutes Stück
weiter in Richtung Klimaneutralität zu
bringen wenn wir diesen Weg konsequent
fortsetzen und diese Chance ergreifen
profitieren wir Herr Kollege Mattfeld
nicht nur als Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland davon ganz herzlichen Dank
nächster Redner für die afd-fraktion
Steffen Portrait
stimmenportraits der energiepolitische
Sprecher der afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren Herr Minister
Habig sie haben jetzt hier die vollen 8
Minuten dafür verwendet über Probleme zu
reden die ohne ihre Politik nicht in
diesem Maße da wären
Klima Historie Klima Historie brauchen
wir nicht denn wir haben Zeit unsere
Gesellschaft residenzfähig zu machen
gegenüber der Klimaänderung
Energieverknappung hätten wir nicht wenn
wir Kohle verstromen würden wenn wir
Kernenergie entsprechend ans Netz
bringen würden und wenn wir russisches
Gas endlich hier zu uns bekommen würden
Energie Verknappung wäre dann passé und
die Preise würden singen ganz einfach
und die Inflation die Inflation wäre
nicht so hoch wenn Sie die EZB
auffordern würden seriöse Geldpolitik zu
machen all das machen sie nicht schade
das schade unser Land aber was sie
machen ihn ist leider den Finger ins
Ausland zeigen auf die schlimmen Dinge
in der Ukraine ja aber das hat nicht die
Probleme bei uns verursacht Herr
Minister nein
meine Damen und Herren vor 100 10 Jahren
ist die Titanic untergegangen berauscht
von der Überzeugung der Machbarkeit
ihrer Technologie wurden vielfältige
Warnungen vor Eisbergen in den Wind
geschlagen Funksprüche informierten über
Packeis und einem riesigen Eisfeld doch
Kapitän und Offiziere jeden strandkurs
und die Katastrophe nahmen ihren Lauf
und genauso ist es heute mit der
Energiewende ins Nichts jedes geradewegs
in die Insolvenz Deutschlands in den
Untergang unseres Wohlfahrtsstaates und
wir im Fall der Titanic gibt es heute
Warnungen zu auf Eon-Chef Birnbaum z.B
prognostizierte schon vor einem Jahr
dass wir in diesen Winter mit
Abschaltung ganzer Städte rechnen können
auch das Bundesamt für
Bevölkerungsschutz und Katastrophenhilfe
äußerte sich ähnlich um nur diese beiden
zu nennen und wie bei der Titanic fahren
die Verantwortlichen weiter munter volle
Kraft voraus Kurs aufs Riff
Großunternehmen
Großunternehmen setzen sich ab sehen
keine Zukunft mehr in einem Links-
von links grünen Ideologen Betonköpfen
und Politik Pfuschern regierten
Deutschland wer seine Produktion nicht
verlagern kann wie zum Beispiel der
Mittelstand erlebt eine Pleitewelle
sondern gleichen der Mittelstand der aus
eigener Kraft lebt und deshalb politisch
unabhängig ist der war globalistischen
Diktat freuen schon immer einen Dorn im
Auge der Mittelstand soll geschwächt
werden damit die Klaus schwarze
Umgestaltung unserer Gesellschaft
unserer Wirtschaft in die Planwirtschaft
weitergehen kann meine Damen und Herren
das steckt dahinter und auch sie haben
Minister Habeck sie haben den Fahrplan
doch leider in Richtung Vergangenheit
sie wollen sich um
coole Sachen kümmern wie sie sagen und
wofür wollen Sie denn diese Steuergelder
ausgeben für Batteriezellen für
Elektrolyse für Sonnen- und Windstrom
also alles Techniken aus dem letzten
oder vorletzten Jahrhundert alles
Techniken die lebenslang nicht ohne
Subventionen auskommen können meine
Damen und Herren kaum ein Wort zu
zukunftsweisender Industrie und Dinge
die Zukunft schaffen meine Damen und
Herren diese Bundesregierung hat fertig
die Feststellung von Stefan kotré von
der AFD der Bundestag debattiert über
den Einzelplan 009 Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz
14,57 Milliarden hatte Robert Habeck zur
Verfügung es sind 3,1% des
Gesamthaushaltes immerhin Andreas
mit der Titanic auf den Eisberg zu
fahren das sind sie beim Thema
Klimaschutz
Olaf Scholz hat bei der
Weltklimakonferenz in Sharm el-Sheikh
sehr deutlich eingefordert wir brauchen
mehr Tempo und mehr Ehrgeiz beim Umstieg
auf erneuerbare Energien mit diesem
Vorsatz sind wir als Ampel angetreten
und diesen Vorsatz setzen wir um das
zeigt nicht zuletzt der Haushalt den wir
heute beschließen werden
meine Damen und Herren natürlich bildet
der Haushalt die aktuelle
Krisensituation ab und ermöglicht uns
dass wir entschlossen gegen die hohen
Energiepreise Vorgehen wir haben letzte
Sitzungswoche die dezemberhilfe
beschlossen die Sie Herr sparen vorher
leider vergessen haben heute beschließt
das Kabinett den Gesetzentwurf für die
Gas und strompreisbremse
aber neben diesen kurzfristigen
notwendigen Maßnahmen schaffen wir es
natürlich trotzdem unseren Fokus auf
Klimaschutz und Energie zu legen
zusätzlich zu all den
Entlastungsmaßnahmen müssen wir
gleichzeitig genauso dringend auch die
Weichen für unsere Energieversorgung der
Zukunft stellen wir müssen schnell weg
von Kohle Öl und Gas wir brauchen eine
nachhaltige und sozialgerechte
Energiewende und wir müssen die
Industrie erfolgreich dekarbonisieren
nur wenn wir der Welt zeigen dass dieser
Weg gut funktioniert haben wir noch eine
Chance die Erderwärmung auf 1,5 Grad zu
begrenzen
meine Damen und Herren viele der
notwendigen Maßnahmen brauchen aber
entsprechende finanzielle
Rahmenbedingungen damit sie auch
umgesetzt werden diese Rahmenbedingungen
schaffen wir mit dem Haushalt den wir
heute beschließen die Ausgaben die wir
dort vorsehen für den Klimaschutz sind
gut angelegt das Geld weil wir es in
eine klimaneutrale Zukunft investieren
Investitionen in CO2-freien Strom sind
ein zentraler Baustein die
Karbonisierung bedeutet aber auch
Investitionen in eine andere Mobilität
in energieeffiziente Gebäude und den
Grünen Produktionsprozesse 35 Milliarden
Euro werden wir nächstes Jahr dafür aus
dem Klima und transformationsfonds
bereitstellen wir gehen damit alle
wichtigen Bereiche an in denen wir
schnell Emissionen einspannen müssen 16
Milliarden Euro sind für mehr Effizienz
und mehr erneuerbare im Gebäudebereich
vorgesehen
4 Milliarden geben wir für Elektroautos
und zusätzliche Ladesäulen aus mit 2,2
Milliarden Euro unterstützen wir
klimaneutrale Industrieprozesse und mit
1,2 Milliarden Euro den Einsatz von
grünem Wasserstoff aber auch viele
kleine Projekte die wir im Klima und
transformationsfonds finanzieren helfen
die Energiewende voranzutreiben das neue
Aufbauprogramm Wärmepumpen mit 15
Millionen zum Beispiel
der Klima und Transformation steht bei
der Finanzierung des Klimaschutz für den
Mittelpunkt aber auch im eigenen
Haushalt des klimaschutzministeriums
setzen wir wichtige Schwerpunkte wir
stellen fast 700 Millionen Euro für die
Energieforschung und die real Labore der
Energiewende zur Verfügung für den
Klimaschutz und den Schutz der
Biodiversität im Ausland sind es 710
Millionen und für den internationalen
Aufbau der Wasserstoffwirtschaft können
wir die nächsten vier Jahre können wir
die nächsten Jahre fast vier Milliarden
Euro Festplatten und wenn Sie lieber
Junge den ersten fordern Mittel für den
internationalen Klimaschutz zu streichen
brauchen Sie sich über schlechte
Bewertungen ihre Oppositionsarbeit
leider nicht wundern
meine Damen und Herren mit dem Haushalt
untermauern wir unseren Weg zum
klimaneutralen Wirtschaften zur
klimaneutralen Mobilität und zum
klimaneutralen heizen Klimaschutz
Versorgungssicherheit und Entlastungen
das bringen wir mit diesem Haushalt
alles zusammen
nächster Redner für die FDP-Fraktion
Olaf in der Weg
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren nach intensiven
Beratung schließen wir nun den
Einzelplan 09 für das Bundesministerium
für Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz es liegt
ein Haushalt vor der einerseits die
Schlagkraft unseres
Wirtschaftsstandortes und Mittelstandes
erhält und andererseits wichtige Impulse
beim Klimaschutz und bei Innovation
setzt im Haushalt liegt ein besonderer
Fokus auf der Sicherung der
Energieversorgung hier wird gezielt
investiert um die Energiesicherheit in
Deutschland in diesen und in den
kommenden Wintern zu gewährleisten
die neuen die neuen lng-terminals die in
Rekordzeit errichtet werden und ich
finde 194 Tage in Wilhelmshaven wirklich
beeindruckend
ja da dürfen glaube ich auch mal
klatschen
das ist aber nur ein Beispiel wie wir
die Bundesmittel gezielt und im
bürokratisch einsetzen und investieren
und obwohl wir die Energieversorgung
sicherstellen werden wir nicht alle
gestiegenen Belastungen als Staat
abfedern können neben den Bürgern und
dem Mittelstand werden wir vor allem die
energieintensive Industrie aber spürbar
entlasten können das ist gut wir stellen
sicher dass der Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland erhalten bleibt und
weiterhin gestärkt wird wir sorgen
weiterhin dafür dass durch Umschichtung
bei Investitionsprogramm deutlich
stärkere Ansätze für mehr Klimaschutz in
der Industrie gesetzt werden denn
vielmehr
denn viel mehr als staatliche Vorgaben
brauchen wir die Innovationskraft der
deutschen Industrie für echten wirksamen
Klimaschutz unsere Aufgabe
unsere Aufgabe als Deutscher Bundestag
gemeinsam mit der Bundesregierung ist es
hier für optimale Rahmenbedingungen zu
sorgen und diese Innovationskraft
brauchen wir auch für den
internationalen Klimaschutz denn andere
Staaten können genauso von neuen
Technologien profitieren hier müssen wir
auch den Handel deutlich vorantreiben
mit der internationalen
Klimaschutzinitiative unterstützen wir
zudem auch Entwicklungsländer bei
Maßnahmen zur Biodiversität denn das ist
unsere Verantwortung wobei natürlich
immer die Überprüfung der Maßnahmen
erforderlich ist und bleibt ein weiterer
wichtiger Baustein ist die
wasserstoffstrategie die ebenfalls in
diesem Haushalt verankert ist wir nutzen
auch hier die Chancen der Globalisierung
und stellen uns auf den schnellen
Hochlauf vom Wasserstoff ein denn dabei
dürfen wir unter keinen Umständen den
Anschluss verlieren hier müssen wir wie
gerade schon angesprochen mit der EU
zügig Antworten auf den Vorstoß aus den
USA finden
uns und zu guter Letzt liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen um die Energiewende
umzusetzen brauchen wir vor allem aber
Menschen Menschen die anpacken wir
brauchen wir haben bereits jetzt einen
massiven Fachkräftemangel und deshalb
ist es gut dass wir auch die berufliche
Bildung im Handwerk mit diesem Haushalt
stärken die Handwerkerinnen und
Handwerker sind die Klimaschützer unsere
Zeit sie sie verdienen nicht nur unsere
Wertschätzung und Unterstützung sondern
wir werden dafür sorgen dass es
zukünftig noch viel mehr von ihnen gibt
diese Haushalt ist geprägt von Weitsicht
und Fortschritt und genau das brauchen
wir nicht nur in diesen
Herausforderungen Zeiten vielen Dank
Olaf in der Weg war das für die FDP der
nächste Redner hier am letzten Tag der
Haushaltsdebatte zum Einzelplan 09
Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz ist
Hans-jürgen Durst für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren bei den
Haushaltsberatungen im März hat
Wirtschaftsminister Habeck kritisiert in
Deutschland würden sich die Menschen nur
noch bewegen wenn Sie einen finanziellen
Klops auf den Hintern bekämen so sehr
würde die Wirtschaft über subventioniert
dieser Haushalt hat ein noch höheres
Niveau doch was dem Haushalt fehlt ist
eine klare Prioritätensetzung Richtung
Zukunft
als Union haben wir Ihnen den Haushalt
in den Haushaltsberatungen ein Angebot
zur Prioritätensetzung unterbreitet denn
wir haben in den Vorschläge für ein
Wachstumspaket vorgestellt dass die
Angebotsseite in den Blick nimmt denn
wir wissen doch in Deutschland werden
die Energiepreise nicht mehr auf das
Niveau von vor der ukraine-krise
zurückfallen und deswegen müssen wir in
anderen Bereichen umso besser werden um
die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit international
auch wieder herzustellen und zu
erreichen
neue Ideen
neue Ideen und der Reformbereitschaft
spiegelt dieser Haushalt aber viel zu
wenig wieder
wer mit den Unternehmern in unserem Land
spricht der hört vor allem drei Themen
mit denen sie sich tagtäglich intensiv
auseinandersetzen die sie umtreiben
sitzt zuallererstes Thema Inflation und
Energiepreise zum zweiten ist es das
Thema nach wie vor Lieferketten und zum
dritten der Mangel an Fachkräften
mittlerweile im Grunde in allen Branchen
während die Ampel die Wirtschaft bei den
ersten entlastungspaketen komplett
vergessen hat haben wir als Union
konkrete Vorschläge dazu vorgelegt
und Priorität Nummer eins muss sein die
Belastungen der Wirtschaft müssen
gesenkt werden seit Monaten fordern wir
ein belastungsmoratorium eine Zeit lang
haben wir das auch von der FDP gehört
bisher allerdings Fehlanzeige helfen
würde auch die Beschleunigung von
Planungs- und Genehmigungsverfahren ist
mehrfach in der Debatte angesprochen
worden in Zusammenhang mit lng-terminals
hat das sehr gut funktioniert aber wir
brauchen es eben auch in sämtlichen
anderen Bereichen und die drastische
Reduzierung der Bürokratie davon hören
wir uns sehen wir im regierungshandel
sehr sehr wenig und schon heute ist klar
dass wir zum Ende des Jahres das Ziel
nämlich sämtliche
Verwaltungsdienstleistungen knapp 600 zu
digitalisieren in Deutschland meilenweit
verfehlen werden die Unternehmen in
unserem Land gerade die kleinen und
mittelständischen die brauchen dringend
Entlastungen
und dann müssen wir die Weichen auf
Zukunft stellen und das passiert zu
wenig in diesem Haushalt wir müssen bei
der nächsten welletechnologischer
Innovationen unbedingt mit dabei sein
und da ist es sehr bemerkenswert dass
der Minister als Beispiel für
Zukunftsfähigkeit in diesem Haushalt
ausgerechnet die Cloud-Technologien und
die digitalen Technologien anspricht in
beiden Bereichen wurde der
Haushaltsentwurf gegenüber dem Vorjahr
deutlich gekürzt in einem Fall sogar um
50% gekürzt bei den
Cloud-Infrastrukturen
und dann ja das sind genau die Zahlen
des Haushalts und dann haben wir Anträge
dazu gestellt genau zu diesen Themen und
im Anschluss wurde im einen Fall
zumindest ein klein wenig und im anderen
Fall deutlich die Haushaltspositionen
aufgestockt das spricht eindeutig dafür
sie sollten sehr viel öfter die Anträge
der Union nicht nur lesen sondern ihnen
auch zustimmen dann sind Sie auf dem
richtigen Weg
natürlich geht es aktuell vor allem
darum die Wirtschaft am Laufen zu halten
es muss aber auch darum gehen die
Weichen in Richtung Zukunft zu stellen
und das schafft dieser Haushalt nicht
vielen Dank
hat noch einmal angesprochen das vor
allen Dingen für den Mittelstand was
getan werden muss die Union hat auch
einen Änderungsantrag dazu und fordert
unter anderem beruflichen Bildung für
den Mittelstand lehrlingsunterweisung
dort einen zusätzlichen Titel von 75
Millionen Euro aufzusetzen Lena Werner
jetzt für die SPD
hat die Regierung es geschafft ein
Haushalt aufzustellen der zeigt dass wir
nicht nur kurzfristige Krisenbewältigung
beherrschen sondern auch langfristig
zukunftsfähige Voraussetzungen für
unsere Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft
schaffen und genau da unterscheidet sich
nämlich auch die Wahrnehmung und darauf
werde ich jetzt darauf eingehen wo wir
zukunftsorientiert investieren werden
wir können nämlich auch Fehler
korrigieren denn vor ein paar Monaten
habe ich genau hier über die Wichtigkeit
der europäischen Projekte gesprochen und
betont dass wir uns weiter am wichtigen
Zukunftsprojekt ipci health beteiligen
müssen und genau das ist uns jetzt in
diesem Haushalt gelungen damit können
wir an die bereits bestehenden
erfolgreichen Projekte anknüpfen und
gemeinsam in Europa wichtige neue
Impulse in der gehen und selbstforschung
vorantreiben
ein weiteres wichtiges Zukunftsthema für
das ich mich als Berichterstatterin
stark einsetze ich ist der Bereich Games
überraschend wurde bekanntgegeben dass
der Topf für alle für die Förderung
ausgeschöpft war und das zeigt wie gut
das Programm angenommen wird und dass
der Bedarf in Deutschland da ist aber
gleichzeitig ist klar dass die Förderung
weiterlaufen muss um in dieser
wachsenden und umkämpften Branche auf
dem europäischen aber auch international
international Markt wettbewerbsfähig zu
bleiben da freue ich mich sehr dass es
kurzfristig gelungen ist hier die Mittel
noch einmal kräftig zu erhöhen das ist
ein starkes Signal an eine innovative
und enorme zukunftsfähige Branche die
Wertschöpfung betreibt und
fachkräftemobilisiert
vielen Dank daher an die Kollegin Anna
casalski und den Kollegen Frank junge
für die gemeinsame Arbeit und die
Unterstützung von diesem wichtigen
Projekt
auch im Tourismus konnten wir noch mal
weitere wichtige Mittel organisieren vor
der Bereinigungssitzung des
Haushaltsausschusses hatten wir bereits
einen mittelaufwuchs von 4,6 Millionen
Euro für die deutsche Zentrale für
Tourismus erwürgen können und es freut
mich ganz besonders dass jetzt noch
weitere 1,5 Millionen Euro dazu kommen
damit steigt das Budget der DZT auf 40,6
Millionen Euro für das Jahr 2023 und
damit können wir die Potenziale des
starke beutelten deutschen Tourismus
weiter stärken
auf der ganzen Welt vermarktete DCT die
Vielfalt des Tourismusland Deutschland
und zu dieser Vielfalt zählt
insbesondere ein nachhaltiger Tourismus
denn unsere Hotels Gastronomie in
Freizeitparks die
Veranstaltungswirtschaft und viele
weitere Unternehmen investieren viel
Herzblut und finanzielle Mittel in einen
nachhaltigen und umweltverträglichen
Tourismus diese Anstrengung erstrecken
sich über viele Bereiche die
Identifizierung von CO2 Einsparpotenzial
die Stärkung des ländlichen Raums und
der damit verbundenen Erschließung neuer
touristischer Potenziale und dem Ausbau
der Kreislaufwirtschaft die DZT trägt
dafür Sorge dass auch international eine
entsprechende Sichtbarkeit für den
nachhaltigen Tourismusstandort
Deutschland geschaffen wird
Nachhaltigkeit Umweltbewusstsein und
klimaneutrales reisen sollen mit einer
Reise nach Deutschland in Verbindung
gebracht werden das soll zu unserem
Markenkern werden und unseren Tourismus
zukunftsfähig machen hier kann die
Tourismusbranche als Impulsgeber und
Katalysator für weitere wirtschaftliche
Branchen in Deutschland dienen und zum
Abschluss meiner Rede würde ich gerne
noch kurz auf das A-Teil eingehen weil
in dieser Woche öfters negativ darüber
gesprochen wurde man kann in das aata
Reisen die Menschen dort freuen sich
sehr auf sie und sie heißen sie auch
sehr gerne willkommen und deswegen
meiner pay fahren Sie gerne hin und
machen sie dort Urlaub vielen Dank
der nächste Redner in der Debatte
Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz Einzelplan 09
ist Robert farle er ist einer von sechs
fraktionslosen Abgeordneten im September
ist er aus der Partei und der Fraktion
der AFD ausgetreten einer von fünf
Austritten schon in dieser
Legislaturperiode bei der AFD
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren der Kern der
deutschen Industrie und der Mittelstand
wird von der ampelregierung im Zuge der
großen Transformation
planmäßig ruiniert
das geschieht auch ganz bewusst mir geht
es darum dass dahinterstehende
Geschäftsmodell der künstlich
herbeigeredeten Klimakrise aufzuzeigen
denn Klimaschutz ist bei Ihnen nur der
denkmantel für ihre wirklichen Ziele
erstens Milliardäre und us-hedgefonds
Manager finanzieren Wissenschaftler für
Auftragsarbeiten die das Märchen von
menschengemachten klimaan Wandel überall
hin transportieren sollen zweitens
dieselben Investoren finanzieren
lobby-organisationen wie die Agora
Energiewende die diese fake-studien als
Grundlage für ihre politischen
Forderungen Nutzen in diesem Fall die
Energiewende diese wiederum dieselben
Investoren in den USA finanzieren
sogenannte klimaaktivisten wie Fridays
for future instinction Rebellion oder
die letzte Generation um ihren
Forderungen Nachdruck zu verleihen und
das Thema in den Medien dauerpräsent zu
halten das Ziel ist dann erreicht wenn
dadurch staatliche
milliardenschwere Investitionsprogramme
ausgelöst werden die für die Profite
derselben Investoren sorgen und das ist
ihre Aufgabe Herr Habeck wie weit der
Einfluss dieser Investoren auf die
Bundesregierung bereits vorangeschritten
ist zeigt sich an den
personalbesetzungen der grün geführten
Ministerien
Annalena perbock hat die
US-amerikanische ex-chefin von
Greenpeace international Jennifer Morgan
zur Staatssekretärin im Auswärtigen Amt
gemacht Robert Habeck hat fast die
komplette spitzenriege seines
Ministeriums gegen Energiewende
Lobbyisten ausgetauscht den ehemaligen
Direktor der Lobby-Organisation agora
Ende Energiewende hat Habeck zum
Staatssekretär ernannt Frau Helga
den größten
us-vermögensverwalter Blackrock tätig
und soll künftig chefökonomin bei
havixministerium werden dazu zitiere ich
aus der Märzausgabe des manager-magazins
Zitat die Protagonisten der
ökoprotestbewegung halten nun die Macht
in der Hand die Rebellen sind jetzt
Regenten er der grüne Staatssekretär
Sven Giegold will die soziale
Marktwirtschaft Ludwig Erhardt in die
ökologisch soziale Marktwirtschaft
Robert habecks umbauen der Umbau der
Volkswirtschaft wird Verlierer haben
Gewinner und super Gewinner großbritäre
großprofiteure der Staatsmilliarden
Zitat Ende die Grünen Minister sind
somit die Handlanger der großprofiteure
der Energiewende die sich den Staat als
der bedienungs-
sichern während umgekehrt die
traditionellen Industrien die
Automobilindustrie die Chemieindustrie
und andere Industrie praktisch gezwungen
werden dieses Land zu verlassen weil die
Energiepreise für sie nicht mehr
bezahlbar sind und das kostet
hunderttausende Arbeitsplätze sie haben
es sind an dieses
realisierungsminister der die
Exportnation Deutschland auslöschen soll
vielen Dank
Robert fahl und schön eingefangen von
unserer Regie der zuständige Minister
der ja hier auch mehrfach Adressat war
der Rede von Robert Vahle fraktionsloser
Abgeordnete im Deutschen Bundestag
nächster Redner in der Debatte Timon
gremmels für die SPD-Fraktion
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren Herr Fahne für diese
guten Verschwörungstheorien hätten sie
gar nicht aus der afd-fraktion austreten
müssen das passt da ganz hervorragend zu
wer muss man muss man an dieser Stelle
dazu nicht sagen ja wir beraten heute
den Einzelplan 09 dass Budget des
Ministeriums für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz ich finde diese beiden
Themen Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz
Energiewende das gehört zusammen wie ja
wir sind eingefallen Parlament hat das
passt hervorragend weil genauso geht
Energiewende wir wollen natürlich unser
Wirtschaftssystem umbauen wir wollen es
nachhaltig machen wir wollen es
resilient machen wir wollen es
zukunftsgerichtet ausbauen das ist die
Aufgabe die unsere Generation jetzt hier
hat ein weiter so wird sozusagen das in
den einzelnen Abgrund führen und das
wäre verantwortungslose Politik wenn wir
hier auf die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der CDU und anderen hören meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren und deswegen
haben wir richtige Weichen gestellt der
Fokus war jetzt immer auf ng-ports of
gas Einspeicherung auf Verträge auf
Atomkraft wir haben viel zu wenig
darüber hier geredet was diese Regierung
gemacht hat um die erneuerbaren Energien
voranzubringen das EEG 2023 ist das
modernste und fortschrittlichste gesetzt
was dazu führt dass wir den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien schnell
voranbringen zügig voranbringen wir
werden in Zukunft von Windkraft von
photovoltai von Biomasse stärken und
ausbauen
Wärmepumpen auf was mir und uns jetzt
aber wichtig ist dass wir möglichst viel
der industriellen Wertschöpfung für
diese Bereiche in Deutschland halten und
auch wieder ansiedeln das ist nämlich
moderne Industriepolitik und deswegen
brauchen wir eine europäische
abgestimmte Antwort auf beides Inflation
reduction Act das ist notwendig weil
wenn wir jetzt nicht schnell solche
Antworten geben werden Unternehmen
abwandern weil die Dinge die da aus den
USA kommen so spannend und interessant
sind und ich fand das ja ganz
interessant als Herr Merz in seiner Rede
hier zum Generaldebatte auch auf den
Inflation reduction Act eingegangen ist
das als vorbildlich bezeichnet hat
spannend nur ist das sozusagen die Union
gegen die Klima und Transformation klagt
das passt doch alles nicht zusammen weil
da stecken genau auch ein Teil der Mitte
drin die wir für den Umbau der
Industriegesellschaft dringend brauchen
das was sie machen ist in konsequent
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
von der Union ja und deswegen müssen wir
jetzt aufpassen dass wir bei dem
Gesetzesentwurf der ja heute im Kabinett
und dann in den nächsten Wochen im
Bundestag den nächsten beiden Wochen
beraten verabschiedet wird zur Gas und
strompreisbremse der richtig und wichtig
ist aber wir müssen hier die richtigen
Signale aussenden wir dürfen es nicht
zulassen dass wir Signale aussenden dass
die Unternehmen und die Branchen die wir
brauchen um die Energiewende
hinzukriegen die erneuerbaren Energien
dass die Signale bekommen dass sozusagen
hier übermäßig Gewinne abgeschöpft
werden und deswegen müssen wir
klugerweise und richtigerweise darüber
nachdenken ob es nicht Mittel und Wege
gibt wie eine reinvestitionsquote zu
verankern darüber sollten wir noch mal
in den nächsten zwei Wochen wirklich
unsere Köpfe zusammenstecken weil sonst
ist es das falsche Signal was wir senden
oder wir müssen auch darüber nachdenken
ob wir nicht die Vergütungssätze im
Bereich Photovoltaik den sogenannten
Deckel auch wieder anheben weil gerade
die Kosten zeigen und es wäre doch
wirklich nicht vermittelbar nach außen
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
ich glaube dass das
Wirtschaftsministerium und Robert
Habegger auf einen guten Weg ist der
Roundtable den sie am Montag zum Ausbau
der Produktionskapazitäten für die
Energiewende auf die Weg gebracht haben
und wo sie die ersten Ergebnisse
verkündet haben ist vielversprechend wir
müssen da vielleicht noch ein Stück
schneller werden ich weiß ihr
Ministerium arbeitet an der
Kapazitätsgrenze aber wir müssen jetzt
schnell Antworten darauf finden damit
wir möglichst viel der Wertschöpfung der
Erneuerbaren Industrie in Deutschland in
Europa halten in diesem Sinne glück auf
Tim und gremmels für die SPD und die
nächste Rednerin die kennen Sie
sicherlich noch meine Damen und Herren
Anja Karliczek ja hier gibt es auch noch
von der cdu/csu immer ein
Bundesbildungsministerin und sie ist in
dieser Legislaturperiode die
tourismuspolitische Sprecherin der
Unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
die die
branchenen Menschen schon mal einmal
erwähnt hat nämlich die Tourismusbranche
und ich bin in diesen Tagen sehr viel
unterwegs in Hotelerie und Gastronomie
bei Reisebüro ist bei
Reisebusunternehmen bei
Tourismusverbänden vor Ort und ich höre
überall und deswegen sind diese 0,4 %
plus bei der Wirtschaftsleistung auch
zustande gekommen der Sommer war gut
aber die Aussicht auf den Winter
bereitet große Sorgen die finanzielle
Lage nach den corona-
ist ja 2019 die Einkaufspreise
explodieren übrigens nicht nur bei Gas
und Strom Fachkräfte werden händeringend
gesucht am Flughafen genauso wie im
Gastgewerbe und deswegen ist eine gute
Wintersaison für die Tourismusbranche
von existenzieller Bedeutung und deshalb
ist es maximal kontraproduktiv wenn der
amtierende Gesundheitsminister immer
wieder corona-alarm schlägt denn
unwegbarkeit schädigt das Geschäft dann
fahren die Menschen woanders hin und das
können wir glaube ich alle miteinander
nicht wollen
und weil diese Branche wieder mitten im
Sturm steht wäre es gut wenn diese
Regierung und diese tragenden Fraktionen
endlich begreifen das Planungssicherheit
in volatilen Zeiten ein Wert an sich ist
wir werden uns auf steigende
Volatilitäten einstellen müssen und mehr
Volatilität bedeutet unternehmer müssen
flexibler reagieren können und deswegen
sind mehr Vorschriften mehr Regeln in
diesen Tagen mehr Gift denn je lassen
Sie unternehmen etwas unternehmen und
dann werden sie mit Unwägbarkeiten
dieser Tage schon fertig die Branche mit
ihren mehr als 3 Millionen Beschäftigten
erwartet übrigens auch dass sie ihnen
bald möglichst mal etwas sagen zu der
Entfristung des ermäßigten
Mehrwertsteuersatzes auch das ist
Planungssicherheit in diesen Tagen der
Bundeskanzler der Finanzminister haben
das mehrfach versprochen und bisher
gebrochen und damit erhielten zum
Beispiel die Unternehmerinnen und
Unternehmer die genau in diesen Tagen
mit jedem zu kämpfen müssen die
Planungssicherheit die Sie brauchen um
mehr Mitarbeiter anzuwerben und auch
weitere Investitionen gerade in das
Thema Nachhaltigkeit tätigen zu können
einen weiteren Punkt will ich Ihnen noch
mit auf den Weg geben Frau hehdorfer die
Chefin der deutschen Zentrale für
Tourismus hat in einer der letzten
Anhörungen sehr gut beschrieben worum es
aktuell im Tourismus geht sie sagte in
Krisenzeiten werden Marktanteile neu
verteilt der Kampf um neue
zahlungskräftige Gäste ist weltweit und
europaweit in aller Heftigkeit entbrannt
rund um Deutschland investieren viele
Regierungen massiv in den Ausbau ihrer
Werbung für den heimischen Tourismus und
mit knapp sechs Millionen Euro Frau
werner hat angesprochen im nächsten Jahr
für die DZT wird Deutschland in diesem
Wettbewerb nicht die Nase vorn haben sie
haben damit den Haushalt streiten mit
dem Haushalt 23 immer noch nicht das
Niveau von 2021 erreicht sie müssen
klotzen und kleckern nicht und kleckern
nicht in dieser Situation
und
Deutschland ist ein hoch angesehenes
Reiseland kulturell in der mit der Natur
kulinarisch aber was hilft das wenn das
am Ende viel zu wenige wissen wir
brauchen gerade jetzt gerade jetzt wo
alles teurer wird die gut zahlende
Kundschaft aus aller Welt und wenn sie
nur dort werben von wo man mit Bus und
Bahn nach Deutschland kommen kann dann
werden wir genau diesen Zug verpassen
und dann kommen wir immer wieder das
Zitat der Chefin in den Sinn in der
Krise werden die Marktanteile neu
verteilt nur leider Deutschland wird
nicht der Profiteur davon sein zum
Leidwesen der vielen vielen Menschen dem
Tourismus arbeiten
Anja Karliczek die tourismuspolitische
Sprecherin der Unionsfraktion und der
letzte Redner hier zum Einzelplan 09
Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz kommt von der
SPD Hannes walte er stellvertretender
Vorsitzender des Wirtschaftsausschusses
Kollegen von neun Monaten begann der
völkerrechtswidriger Angriff Russlands
auf die Ukraine seither sehen wir bei
einer täglich Russland lässt nichts
unversucht ein Keil und unsere
Gesellschaft zu treiben ob gaserpressung
das Verbreiten von Fake News oder
Cyberangriffe auf Unternehmen die Liste
lässt sich beliebig fortsetzen sicher
ist aber unsere Gesellschaft ist stark
unsere Wirtschaft des resilient wir
setzen uns mit der geballten Kraft
unseres Landes für unsere gemeinsamen
Werte und unsere Freiheit ein
dem Einzelplan 09 kommt hierbei eine
Schlüsselrolle zu das sehen wir
beispielhaft am zukunftspaket zur
Transformation der raffineriestandorte
Schwedt und Leuna damit sorgen wir dafür
dass Deutschland unabhängiger vom
russischen Öl wird deshalb investieren
wir in den nächsten zehn Jahren 375
Millionen Euro an Bundesmitteln in die
Sicherung und die erfolgreiche
Transformation der ostdeutschen
raffineriestandort und Häfen
darüber hinaus stellt der Bund 400
Millionen Euro zu Ertüchtigung der
Pipeline Rostock spät zur Verfügung
damit machen wir klar wir lassen uns
nicht erpressen wir machen uns
unabhängig und wir investieren
gleichzeitig in die Zukunft
Ostdeutschlands
wir sorgen dafür dass Arbeitsplätze
erhalten und neu geschaffen werden damit
geben wir den Menschen Sicherheit
Sicherheit in herausfordernden Zeiten
das Beispiel schwebt zeigt die Krise zu
managen und unser Land dabei
zukunftsfest zu machen sind zwei Seiten
einer Medaille heute legen wir den
Grundstein für den Wohlstand von morgen
und hier setzt die Ampel die richtigen
Akzente wir investieren in die
Innovationskraft unserer Wirtschaft um
im internationalen Wettbewerb mithalten
zu können brauchen wir innovative
Unternehmen den zentralen
Innovationsprogramm Mittelstand kurz-
[Applaus]
gerade weil es schon so oft hier erwähnt
wurde heute bin ich auch sicher dass
ganz viele von ihnen auch Unternehmen in
ihrem Wahlkreis haben die von dem Zimt
profitieren können bei mir zum Beispiel
ist es die schönborner Armaturen GmbH
mit dem engagierten Geschäftsführer
Stich regelmäßig im Austausch und genau
solche Beispiele zeigen dieses
Unternehmen
ist erfolgreich und das gibt dem
Programm recht
ich bin daher froh dass wir nach
zwischenzeitlichen Problemen wieder mit
voller Fahrt unterwegs sind die
deutlicher Erhöhung des gesamtitels auf
700 Millionen Euro für das nächste
Haushaltsjahr ist ein wichtiges Signal
an unseren Mittelstand
wichtig ist auch dass wir die gute
Qualität der dualen Ausbildung weiter
investieren nicht dass seit diesem Jahr
suchen Unternehmen in allen Regionen und
Branchen händeringend nach Fachkräften
gerade das Handwerk steht vor großen
Herausforderungen dabei brauchen wir
hier in Zukunft noch mehr gut
qualifizierter Fachkräfte ohne sie
werden wir den Strukturwandel und auch
die Energiewende nicht schaffen es geht
darum Solaranlagen auf Dächer zu
installieren Heizungsanlagen in
Wohnhäusern zum modernisieren und
Gebäude effizienter zu machen als
handwerksbeauftragter der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion geht natürlich
mein großer Dank auch an Frank junge
Frank Junge hat immer ein wachen Blick
für das Handwerk und setzt sich dafür in
dem Haushaltsausschuss auch immer ganz
hervorragend ein vielen Dank
deswegen die Kürzung des Titels über
betriebliche lehrlingsunterweisung für
ursprünglich im Haushalt vorgesehen
passt einfach nicht in unsere Zeit es
ist richtig und wichtig dass dieser
Fehler im parlamentarischen Verfahren
korrigiert wurde mit nun 70 Millionen
Euro sind wir ein wichtiges Signal an
das Handwerken wir meinen es ernst wir
werden die duale Ausbildung stärken und
wir sorgen weiterhin für eine gute
Qualität der Ausbildung
sie sehen wir haben einen guten
Haushaltsentwurf und parlamentarischen
Verfahren noch besser gemacht jetzt
haben wir einen Haushalt der Sicherheit
in schwierigen Zeiten gibt und
gleichzeitig Investitionen in unsere
Zukunft ermöglicht vielen Dank und
Glückauf
ich schließe die Aussprache wir kommen
zur Abstimmung über den Einzelplan 09
Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz in der ausschussfassung
hierzu liegen ein Änderungsantrag der
Fraktion der cdu/csu sowie eine
Änderungsantrag der Fraktion der AFD vor
wir kommen zum Änderungsantrag der
Fraktion der cdu/csu auf Drucksache
4554 wer stimmt dafür
ja die cdu/csu fordert mehr Geld für die
berufliche Bildung und für die
Mittelstand sowie für Fachkräfte
Sicherungen im September hatten wir ein
Fachkräftemangel von 873.000 Menschen in
Deutschland
gut der Änderungsantrag ist gegen die
Stimmen der CDU CSU-Fraktion und der
Fraktion Die Linke
mit den Stimmen der Koalitionsfraktionen
und der afd-fraktion abgelehnt
Änderungsantrag der Fraktion der AFD auf
Drucksache
4.55 wer stimmt dafür
die AFD wiederum will die Streichung ein
einzelner Titel unter anderem die Kraft
sie Fachkräfte Sicherung pardon für
kleine und mittlere Unternehmen weil
hierdurch aktiv Menschen aus fremden
Kulturkreisen zusätzlich zu bereits
vorhandenen Migration zu Einwanderung
nach Deutschland ermuntert wird würden
dann kommen
wir zur mitgekriegt wurde abgelehnt
ausschussfassung wer stimmt dafür
danke wer stimmt dagegen das ist jetzt
über den Einzelplan 09
14,57 Milliarden Euro hat Robert Habeck
im kommenden Jahr zur Verfügung
angenommen ich rufe auf den Einzelplan
32 bundesschuld mit der
Beschlussempfehlung des
Haushaltsausschusses auf Drucksache
3.5 die bundesschuld ist enorm
angestiegen kein Wunder bei den vielen
Krediten die aufgenommen werden müssen
auf
42,178 Milliarden Euro mal ein Vergleich
der Bildungsetat hat einen Rekordwert
von 21 Milliarden Euro das ist genau die
Hälfte
wir stimmen ab über den Einzelplan 32
bundesschuld mit der Beschlussempfehlung
des Haushaltsausschusses auf Drucksache
3.524 die Berichterstattung haben die
Abgeordneten Dennis rodem Christian
Haase Sven Christian Kindler Otto Fricke
Peter Böhringer und dr Gesine Lötzsch
eine Aussprache ist nicht vorgesehen wir
kommen daher gleich zur Abstimmung über
den Einzelplan 32 Hunde Schuld in der
ausschussfassung wer stimmt dafür im
Regierungsentwurf waren 10 Milliarden
weniger vorgesehen wurde dann vom
Haushaltsausschuss notgedrungen in
nachgerüstet auf
42,1 Milliarden
die Linke wer enthält sich niemand der
Einzelplan 32 ist angenommen
ich rufe auf den Einzelplan 60
allgemeine Finanzverwaltung mit der
Beschlussempfehlung des
Haushaltsausschusses auf Drucksache
3.525 die Berichterstattung haben die
Abgeordneten Dennis rodem dr Thorsten
Rudolf Christian Hasen die allgemeine
Finanzverwaltung bekam auch wesentlich
mehr Geld als ursprüngliche plant
nämlich plus 6,4 Milliarden Euro und ist
jetzt ebenfalls bei 42,2 Milliarden Euro
also die Steuerverwaltung die unter
anderem für Festsetzungen Erhöhung von
Steuern zuständig ist viel Geld dafür 42
Milliarden
Abstimmung über den Einzelplan 60
allgemeine Finanzverwaltung in der
ausschussfassung wer stimmt dafür
die Koalitionsfraktionen wer stimmt
dagegen
die cdu/csu-fraktion die afd-fraktion
und die Fraktion DIE LINKE wer enthält
sich
niemand der Einzelplan 60 ist angenommen
ich rufe auf den Entwurf des
Haushaltsgesetzes
2023 mit den Beschlussempfehlungen des
Haushaltsausschusses auf den Drucksachen
3.527 so meine Damen und Herren und
jetzt wird wieder so üblich ist
über das Haushaltsgesetz
2023 hier in zweiter Lesung quasi
abgestimmt also das ist der gesamte
Brocken der seit Dienstag hier beraten
wurde
476,3 Milliarden Euro für 2023
Böhringer und dr Gesine Lötzsch es
liegen zwei Änderungsanträge der
Fraktion Die Linke vor über die wir
gleich abstimmen werden eine weitere
Aussprache in der zweiten Beratung ist
nicht vorgesehen wir kommen zur
Abstimmung in der zweiten Beratung der
Haushaltsausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf den Drucksachen
3.527 und
3528 den Entwurf eines Haushaltsgesetzes
2023 in der ausschussfassung anzunehmen
zunächst stimmen wir über zwei
Änderungsanträge der Fraktion DIE LINKE
Änderungsantrag auf Drucksache
4.552 wer stimmt dafür da fordert DIE
LINKE die Geschlechtergerechtigkeit bei
Planung und Vollzug des Bundeshaushalts
der Änderungsantrag ist mit den Stimmen
der Koalitionsfraktionen der
cdu/csu-fraktion der afd-fraktion gegen
die Stimmen der Fraktion DIE LINKE
abgelehnt
Änderungsantrag auf Drucksache
4.553 wer stimmt dafür auch dieser
Änderungsantrag der Linken die fordert
Entlastung der Exekutive von lobbydruck
ist mit den Stimmen der
Koalitionsfraktionen der
cdu/csu-fraktion der afd-fraktion gegen
die Stimmen der Fraktionen die Linke
abgelehnt
wir kommen nun zur Abstimmung über den
Entwurf eines Haushaltsgesetzes
2023 in der ausschussfassung wer stimmt
dafür
danke wer stimmt dagegen
danke wer enthält sich das
Haushaltsgesetz 2023 ist damit in
zweiter Beratung mit den Stimmen der
Koalitionsfraktionen gegen die Stimmen
der Oppositionsfraktion angenommen
wir kommen nun zum Finanzplan des Bundes
2022 bis 2026 auf den Drucksachen
3101 und
3102 der Haushaltsausschuss empfiehlt in
seiner Beschlussempfehlung auf der
Drucksache
3.529 den Finanzplan zur Kenntnis zu
nehmen wer stimmt für diese
Beschlussempfehlung
danke wer stimmt dagegen
danke wer enthält sich
die Beschlussempfehlung ist mit den
Stimmen der
Koalitionsfraktionen der
cdu/csu-fraktion der Fraktion DIE LINKE
gegen die Stimmen der afd-fraktion
angenommen
ich rufe auf den Tagesordnungspunkt
römisch 2
dritte Beratung des Haushaltsgesetzes
dazu liegen Entschließungsanträge vor
ein Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion
der cdu/csu vier Entschließungsanträge
der Fraktion der AFD sowie ein
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion DIE
LINKE über das Haushaltsgesetz 2023
stimmen wir später namens
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
90 Minuten beschlossen ich eröffne die
Aussprache ja meine Damen und Herren und
jetzt also am Ende einer haushaltswoche
wie das üblich ist noch einmal eine
90-minütige Aussprache über den
Gesamthaushalt und der erste Redner ist
Helge braun der Vorsitzende des
Haushaltsausschusses von der cdu/cs
schon in der ersten lesungsrunde haben
erfahrene Haushälter gesagt diese
Haushaltsberatungen die werden aufwendig
werden und alles andere als einfach eine
Krise mit so vielen Herausforderungen
und darüber hinaus auch die Inflation
das wird viel Arbeit werden und so war
es auch die Änderungsliste alleine der
Regierung gegenüber dem Haushaltsentwurf
war 500 Seiten stark und damit ziemlich
rekordverdächtig aus den Reihen der
verschiedenen Fraktionen haben wir in
der Bereinigungssitzung
1498 Anträge behandelt und wir haben
insgesamt über den Zahlen dieses
Haushaltes 67 Stunden und 20 Minuten
gebrütet alleine die Bereinigungssitzung
die letzte Sitzung hat von 11 Uhr
vormittags bis fünf Uhr 38 gedauert das
sind mehr als 18 Stunden
ich möchte mich bei allen Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ganz herzlich bedanken für
die konzentrierte und faire
Zusammenarbeit darüber hinaus bei den
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern der
Abgeordneten der Fraktionen des bmbf@bmf
und ganz besonders natürlich bei unserem
Ausschuss der kriteriat weil bei diesen
ganzen vielen Änderungsanträgen dass wir
heute hier stehen und sagen können wir
haben präzise festgehalten was wir
beschlossen haben und es ist in bis auf
die letzte Zahl klar worüber wir
abstimmen das ist eine große Arbeit und
deshalb den Mitarbeitern unseres
Ausschuss Sekretärs und ganz herzlichen
Dank danke schön
ich will einen Punkt ansprechen der
unsere Arbeit aber auch erschwert hat
und wo ich die Bundesregierung herzlich
bitte auch darüber noch mal nachzudenken
wir haben in dieser Zeit der Krisen ist
regelmäßig damit zu tun dass wir
kurzfristige entscheidungsbedarfe haben
dieses Parlament hat gezeigt und ich
habe das mehrfach gesagt und ich glaube
da spreche ich auch für alle Haushälter
wenn es wirklich an der Zeit ist
kurzfristig zu entscheiden und
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in der Not bei
Inflation oder irgendwas zu helfen dann
ist der Haushaltsausschuss jederzeit
bereit innerhalb von Tagesfrist
innerhalb von 48 Stunden Entscheidungen
zu treffen an dem parlamentarischen
Abläufen wird das notwendige niemals
scheitern
auf der anderen Seite
haben wir in den letzten Tagen aber auch
erlebt dass die Ankündigung der
Bundesregierung schon sechs Wochen alt
sind das Dinge wie zum Beispiel die
testverordnung und Falke Corona seit
sechs Wochen zur Überarbeitung ansteht
dass dann fünf Wochen und vier Tage die
Bundesregierung sich Zeit lässt die
Dinge vorzubereiten um dann vom
Parlament zu erwarten dass man innerhalb
von drei Tagen die Dinge entscheidet und
da sage ich das kritisiere ich nicht aus
eher puzzellichkeit des Parlamentes
sondern hier geht es um die Qualität von
Gesetzgebungen die Frage ob Experten ob
Länder ob Anhörungen stattfinden können
dass am Ende das Ergebnis unserer
Rechtssetzung gut ist und wenn das die
Aufgabenteilung im zeitlichen Sinne ist
dann ist das falsch und deshalb egal wie
kurz die Frist ist dass man den
Parlament wenigstens auch ein Drittel
der Zeit lässt und die eigenen Beratung
durchzuführen das hielte ich
veranständig und darum möchte ich die
Bundesregierung eindringlich
dieser Haushalt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ist schon jetzt auf Kante
genäht ich will noch ansprechen der
Bundesfinanzminister Christian Lindner
hat eines vorgehabt nämlich fünf
Milliarden als globale Mehrausgabe auf
die Seite zu legen für all die Probleme
die noch kommen weil ansonsten die
haushaltsspielräume komplett
ausgeschöpft sind in der
Bereinigungssitzung ist diese Summe
schon von fünf auf zwei Milliarden
gesunken und der
haushaltsausschusssitzung dieser Woche
haben wir gemerkt dass wir für die eben
schon genannte testverordnung schon 1,2
Milliarden davon belegen müssen das
heißt wir gehen mit einem Haushalt den
wir heute beschließen los der für all
die Unbilden der Krisen des kommenden
Jahres keine Vorsorge trifft das halte
ich für problematisch
einen letzten Punkt weil er in dieser
Haushaltsberatung immer wieder eine
große Rolle gespielt hat nämlich das
Sondervermögen Bundeswehr und die
Haltung des Bundeskanzlers dazu möchte
ich noch thematisieren der Bundeskanzler
ist der mannschaftschef dieser
Bundesregierung und wer die
Kapitänsbinde trägt der hat nicht nur
die Aufgabe und die Verantwortung
sportlich sein Team nach vorne zu
bringen sondern er hat noch eine zweite
Aufgabe nämlich im besonderen Weise
Fairness und Sportlichkeit auch
gegenüber dem Gegner walten zu lassen
und Olaf Scholz hat als Bundeskanzler
mehrfach betont das seine Regierung
jetzt beim Sondervermögen Bundeswehr all
das aufarbeiten muss was die alte
Regierung nicht geschafft hat und als
jemand der der ehemalige Bundesregierung
genauso angehört hat wie Olaf Scholz
kann ich sagen ja auch Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer Angela Merkel und ich
wir müssen den Soldatinnen Soldaten
sagen wir haben uns zwar mehr Geld für
die Bundeswehr und ein klares be bis zum
2% hier gewünscht
und wir sind dafür verantwortlich dass
wir es nicht durchgesetzt haben aber
derjenige gegen den wir nicht mehr
durchgesetzt haben und derjenige der im
Bundeshaushalt sich dagegen gewehrt hat
dass wir das zwei Prozent Ziel klar
reinschreiben sondern stattdessen Wolke
geformulierungen von Richtung
1,5%. das war der Bundesfinanzminister
Olaf Scholz und deshalb hat er eine weit
größere Verantwortung dafür dass wir
heute in dieser Lage sind wir waren des
guten Willens und er ist derjenige an
dem wir da gescheitert sind und deshalb
bin ich deutlich sagen ein
Mannschaftskapitän muss sportlich
Vorbild sein er macht der Kapitänsbinde
keine würde vielen Dank
Helge braun von der CDU der Vorsitzende
des Haushaltsausschusses er hat es
angesprochen eine 18-stündige
Bereinigungssitzung das ist nicht so
spektakulär wie sich es anhört ist es
sehr sehr lang aber die Haushälter haben
immer diese Bereinigungssitzung die
meistens auch sehr lange dauert über
1.000 Anträge und dort ist viel Geld
bewegt worden unter anderem 31
Milliarden mehr beschlossen worden als
vorher festgelegt worden war Bettina
Hagedorn die sich stellvertretende
Vorsitz im Haushaltsausschuss sie ist
von der
spd-binder die hat in unserem
Haushaltsausschuss in den letzten acht
Wochen der Beratung die hast du ja
getragen und ich glaube ich spreche für
alle Haushälter wenn ich hier an dieser
Stelle feststelle ein dickes Dankeschön
geht an unseren
haushaltsausschussvorsitzenden der den
Haushaltsausschuss
Applaus von allen Fraktionen
Kompetenz aber auch sehr viel Stringenz
durch diese Wochen geleitet hast du hast
so Recht darauf hingewiesen wie viele
Seiten wie viele Änderungsanträge es
waren es war ein ganz
bemerkenswerter Haushalt das war meine
21 Bereinigungssitzung und es ist schon
so dass natürlich in Zeiten wo zwischen
dem Kabinettsbeschluss für ein Haushalt
und der Bereinigungssitzung sich die
Welt so dramatisch verändert wie in
diesem Jahr
da kommt es dann auch zur umfangreichen
veränderungs Erfordernissen beim
Haushalt aber wir haben das gut
bewältigt und vielen Dank für deine
kluge Führung an dieser Stelle
das war jetzt
das war jetzt aber genug Lob
denn die behälge Braun du hast gerade
eben auf das 2% Ziel angesprochen und
darum will ich jetzt doch mal ein
bisschen etwas dazu sagen auch wenn ich
sicher bin mein Kollege an die Schweiz
wird das nachher noch näher ausführen
fakt ist jedenfalls
dass wir in der zweiten groko als der
Finanzminister Wolfgang Schäuble ist ein
Verteidigungsetat hatten der so zwischen
im ist zwischen 36 und 37 Milliarden
Euro lag
vier Jahre später als wir die große
Koalition die dritte hatten mit Olaf
Scholz als Finanzminister hatten wir den
Etat pro Jahr auf über 50 Milliarden
gesteigert das ist pro Jahr ein Plus von
13 Milliarden Euro und was das in der
Summe was das in der Summe für das für
die Ausstattung für die Bundeswehr
bedeutet dass es bemerkenswert und
insofern hör auf mit der mehr
Sozialdemokraten hätten hier gestoppt
dass wir für die Ausrüstung der
Bundeswehr und der Soldaten und Soldaten
genug Geld bereitstellen dafür waren wir
immer allerdings die Träume von Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer Deutschland mit einem
Flugzeugträger ausgestatten das war
nicht hatte ich auf unsere Begeisterung
gestoßen
liebe Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen dieser
Haushalt trägt aus unserer Sicht die
Überschrift Zusammenhalt in der
Zeitenwende und wir haben in dieser
Woche ein Haushalt beschlossen der nicht
nur vom Volumen her enorm ist sondern
der auch auf die Erfordernisse der Zeit
die richtigen Antworten gibt in allen
Haushalten die wir hier auf nass also
die nationale Tragweite haben haben wir
enorme Aufstockung beschlossen in dem
Umfang wie sie wirklich erforderlich
sind ich sag nur wir haben auf die
berechtigten Sorgen der Jobcenter gehört
wir haben den Etat für Arbeit und
Soziales z.B um 500 Millionen Euro nur
in diesem Bereich für die aktive
Arbeitsmarktpolitik aus aufgestockt wir
werden dafür Sorge tragen dass gerade in
diesen Zeiten nicht nur die
Arbeitsplätze gesichert bleiben sondern
auch dass Menschen in Qualifizierung
kommen um dann auch qualifiziert der
Arbeitsplätze zu haben wir haben uns
aber auch um die Sorgen der Menschen
gekümmert nicht nur die drei entlastungs
Pakete von fast 100 Milliarden Euro sind
voll finanziert in diesem Haushalt
sondern auch viele viele Dinge ich nenne
nur beispielhaft die größte
Kindergelderhöhung ab 1 Januar überhaupt
auf 250 Euro pro Kind ich nenne nur das
Wohngeld plus dass die
wohngeld-empfänger die
Anspruchsberechtigten verdreifachen wird
und das Wohngeld verbessern wird und all
diese Beiträge die wir heute mit diesem
Haushalt beschließen und liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen insbesondere
die die diesem Haushalt zustimmen werden
also die Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
FDP und Grüne darauf können wir
gemeinsam stolz sein
und es ist auch wichtig dass der diesen
Haushalt des Zusammenhalts in der
Zeitenwende nicht nur auf nationaler
Ebene betrachtet haben und auf
internationale Ebene nicht nur die
Bundeswehr im Blick hatten sondern dass
wir auch den Etage Außenministerin der
den Etat der Ministerin für
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Entwicklung um jeweils eine Milliarde
aufgestockt haben und zusätzlich in der
Bereinigungssitzung aus den Mitteln des
Haushalt des 2022 eine weitere Milliarde
Paris zwischen diesen beiden Ressorts
aufgeteilt zur Verfügung gestellt haben
das sind Beiträge zum Beispiel um die
internationale Ernährungssicherheit
sicherzustellen und die wirken erst im
kommenden Jahr und das ist wichtig und
erforderlich und damit wir Deutschland
sein Beitrag leisten in der Welt denn
die Welt guckt auf uns natürlich ob wir
auch in militärischer Hinsicht konstant
und zuverlässig sind aber sie guckt auch
da drauf ob wir unsere Rolle gerecht
werden die wir in der g7-präsidentschaft
immer wieder bekräftigt haben wir stehen
für Dialog wir stehen für Unterstützung
wir stehen für Solidarität mit der
Ukraine aber was mir wichtig auch ist
auch mit den Anrainerstaaten wie
Moldawien oder Polen die viel viel mehr
Flüchtlinge aufgenommen haben als wir
und darum bin ich sicher dass wir gut
gewappnet sind mit diesem Etat und ich
bedanke mich bei allen die dazu
beigetragen haben und auch ich möchte
mich ganz besonders bei unseren
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern des
Ausschuss Sekretärs bedanken vielen Dank
die Haushälter eine verschworene
Gemeinschaft hier im Deutschen Bundestag
alle wissen was Sie geleistet haben und
vorhin gab es beim Lob an Helge braun
tatsächlich Applaus aus allen Fraktionen
auch von Peter böhringerdem
afd-haushaltspolitischen Sprecher der
jetzt das Wort hat
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin Liebe Steuerzahler
übermorgen ist erster Advent und die
Regierung hat einen Adventskalender
gebastelt öffnen wir die 24 Türchen
die Erweiterung des Bundeskanzleramts
wird durchgezogen die Ampel verteidigt
dass 770 Millionen Euro Projekt obwohl
sie die Planungen noch stoppen könnte
doch Herr Scholz will es ebenso
gigantomanisch wie Frau Merkel haben
die Ampel gönnt sich seit Amtsantritt
10.000 Stellen aufwuchs in ihren
Bundesbehörden meine übertrifft damit
inmitten einer bevorstehenden Rezession
sogar noch die Vorgängerregierung
auch der Bundestag selbst bekommt fast
70 zusätzliche Stellen 2023 das stark
linkslastige Institut für Menschenrechte
bekommt sogar 50 Prozent
personalaufwuchs
6 Milliarden Euro für den neuen IWF vor
resilience and the stayability trust
alles für internationale Corona und
Klimafinanzierung 24 Milliarden fürs
Bürgergeld davon über 10 Milliarden an
ausländische Empfänger
30 Milliarden klimaausgaben aus dem KTF
Kanzler Scholz versprach zudem am 6
November in einer fünf Minuten rede mal
eben ein weiteres milliardenprogramm
fürs Klima für den Planeten mit mehr
Ehrgeiz und Zusammenarbeit mit den
Staaten der Welt mehr Ehrgeiz also gegen
den deutschen Steuerzahler denn
natürlich ist das eine Schiffe für
Deutschland zahlt es
zudem mehr Unterstützung durch
gelegenheitsstrom aus Sonne und Wind für
den Balkan
hinzu kommen absurde eu-klimaprogramme
über die die grüne co2-religion in allen
EU-Ländern durchgesetzt werden soll das
selbe macht die Ampel sogar in Moldawien
und Georgien bei deutschen Verbrauchern
dürfen sich die Energierechnung dagegen
verfünffachen das stört die Ampel nicht
die Ukraine forderte im November mal
eben die Finanzierung ihres
Staatshaushalts die Finanzierung des
ganzen Staatshaushalts die zugehörige
gebekonferenz fand darum gleich hier in
Berlin statt denn ja dann konnten die
deutschen Steuerzahler oder im Namen der
deutschen Steuerzahler die großzügigen
Geber kurze Wege haben in Berlin hier
letztlich ist eine signifikante
Übernahme der Ukraine kriegs- und
Haushaltskosten durch die internationale
Gemeinschaft also Deutschland offenbar
gesetzt bis hin zur 750 Milliarden ist
da alles möglich da die Bundesregierung
ja schon früh einen Blankoscheck
unterschrieben hat
Rüstungsgüter werden dabei oft indirekt
gekauft oder getarnt als Gewährleistung
etwa über die
europeanity der EU oder über
ibf-konstruktion dabei weiß man
natürlich schon heute dass das Geld
niemals zurückfließen wird trotzdem
fordern die Ministerinnen bärburg und
Lambrecht der einzigen Friedenspartei in
grüne und SPD noch mehr Geld für Waffen
für die Ukraine
kohleersatzindustrien man versucht
angeblich die Zukunft der alten
kohle-regionen zu sichern leider jedoch
indem man technologische Sackgassen dort
ansiedelt ich sage das ganz bewusst
wasserstoffprojekte in der geplanten
Form sind Sackgassen oder für die viele
Millionen Euro ernsthaft ein Institut
für elektrifizierte luftfahrtantriebe
oder gar eine Initiative Hybrid
elektrisches fliegen ich sage Ihnen das
ist eine vollabschreibung vom ersten Tag
an
generell wäre es natürlich besser die
alte Industrie an diesen Standorten gar
nicht erst kaputt zu schlagen sondern
sie ganz konservativ konservate zu
bewahren deutsche Kohle wird ja
zunehmend wieder weltmarktfähig und auch
gebraucht aber die Züge die grüne CO2
Religion steht halt im Weg
die permanente uniper-rettung die größte
unternehmensrettung der deutschen
Geschichte ständig wachsende Kosten
Kredite eigenkapitalgeschenke und
Gewährleistung des Bundes an Juniper und
Ablösung von wertlosen finnischen
altkrediten alles in Milliardenhöhe
inzwischen über 50 Milliarden Euro alles
völlig intransparent und das ist immer
noch nicht das Ende der Rechnung
hinzu kommen Milliardenverlust der aus
gasthermin Geschäften der Trading hat
Europe habe ich soll keine
zockergeschäfte mit grundlosem
Gasverkauf auf Termin machen sondern das
teuer mit Steuergeld eingekauft und
eingelagerte Gas einfach exklusiv für
die deutsche Stadtwerke vorhalten leider
geschieht das nicht und wir haben es im
Ausschuss ausführlich erfragt aber es
geschieht nicht man lockt lieber über
terminmarktverkäufe ohne Not und zum
denkbar ungünstigsten Zeitpunkt den
maximalverlust für den deutschen
Steuerzahler und zugleich maximal
Gewinne für internationale Terminmarkt
ca ein ohne sicherzustellen dass das Gas
wenigstens die deutschen Verbrauchern
zugute kommt ein Skandal
[Applaus]
dann absurd hohe 670 Millionen Euro für
die politischen Stiftung die AFD fordert
seit Jahren einen drastischen abwuchs
dieser Position und wir sind noch immer
nicht fertig hier weitere steuergeldt
Türchen die nicht nur überflüssig
sondern sogar schädlich für Deutschland
sind der Verein United for rescue erhält
bis 2026 über 8 Millionen Euro
Steuermittel zur Schleusung von
asyl-förderern an die europäische Küste
und damit natürlich nach Deutschland
mit fremdem Geld haben keinerlei
moralischen Wert die Deutschen wollen
diese Summe nicht für diesen Zweck
eingesetzt wissen
und schon gar nicht perfekt an
Wirtschaft in der Vorsitzende des
Vereins ist ja inzwischen bekanntlich
der Lebensgefährte der
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Göring-Eckardt
diese Position sagt sehr viel über den
moralischen Wert des Gesamthaushalts aus
mit einigen Millionen unterstützen sie
als Steuerzahler auch noch solche netten
Dinge wie
finanzsystemreformen in Marokko oder
urbane Mobilität in Peru steht alles
hier und natürlich unterstützen Sie auch
immer noch die corona-hysterie mit
Milliarden für Tests in Impfdosen
Minister Lauterbach lässt einfach nicht
locker obwohl die corona-maßnahmen nicht
etwa longkowitz das ist eine Lüge
höchstwahrscheinlich seit 2021 zu einer
signifikanten Übersterblichkeit geführt
haben
dann zahlen Sie künftig den Leib und
hochfotografen von Minister Habeck mit
sechsstelligem Jahresgehalt die AFD weiß
warum sie die Öffentlichkeitsarbeit der
gesamten Regierung fast alle Ministerien
drastisch reduzieren will und dann noch
das Adventstürchen 24 mit Millionen von
Euro werden von der CO2 besorgten
Regierung riesige landwirtschaftliche
Nutzflächen die unsere Vorfahren in
Jahrhunderten und vor Jahrhunderten den
Sumpflandschaften entrissenen abgerungen
hatten wir da wieder unter Wasser
gesetzt das ist kein Witz der Ampel ist
also zukünftig mit Kapitänsbinde in
neuen Sümpfen unterwegs den alten
politium bewässert sie ja sowieso
Milliarden schwer verrücktes Deutschland
21 22 ich konnte zum Schluss das war nur
24 kleine Spitzen der Eisbergen kleine
Einblicke in die Tiefen der Abgründe die
sich im linken links-haushalt auftun
überall und für alles ist Geld da nur
nicht für Werktätige deutsche ich
wünsche Ihnen trotzdem einen schönen
ersten Advent aller
vielen Dank
das Wort hat Dr Paula piechotta für die
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer 2023 wird
es dritte Jahr in Folge sein dass nach
einem krisenhaushalt verlangt und wir
gewöhnen uns nicht als Parlament an den
Ausnahmezustand aber wir können
inzwischen ganz gut mit ihm umgehen wir
wissen unter anderem umso
unübersichtlicher die Zeiten umso klarer
müssen die Antworten sein und die
Antworten die dieser Bundeshaushalt gibt
in Sachen Entlastung in Sachen
Modernisierungen Sachen
Energiesicherheit die sind sehr klar in
unübersichtlichen Zeiten wir wachsen
wir wachsen an unseren Aufgaben in der
Krise als Gesellschaft als Bundestag und
auch der Bundeshaushalt wächst mit uns
an diesen großen Aufgaben Friedrich Merz
am Mittwoch und auch Jens Spahn zum
Beispiel heute Vormittag hier die können
ja gar nicht die aktuelle Situation in
Deutschland schwarz genug malen und es
ist ihr gutes Recht das als Opposition
so zu sehen aber ich möchte auf ein paar
frühen die kartonen verweisen die
vielleicht auch deutlich machen dass ich
vielleicht gerade die Stimmung auch ein
bisschen dreht manche meiner Kollegen
würden auf den ifo Geschäftsklimaindex
hinweisen der den zweiten Monaten
vollgesteigt andere auf die deutlich
reduzierenden Energiepreise ich möchte
Ihnen aber noch einen anderen früh in
die Karton nennen der für mich Verein
gemeiner Region wichtig ist ein ganz
feiner Gradmesser dafür wie groß die
materiellen Ängste in dieser
Gesellschaft sind und das ist das
Demonstrationsgeschehen in
Ostdeutschland wir stellen in diesen
Wochen fest weniger Demonstrationen
weniger Teilnehmerinnen bei den
verbliebenen Demonstration und man muss
sagen dieser heiße Herbst den sich so
viele in feuchten Fieberträumen
gewünscht haben der kommt nicht der wird
still und heimlich beerdigt und das ist
ein gutes Zeichen für den Zusammenhalt
in dieser Gesellschaft und da hat auch
der Bundeshaushalt Anteil daran
was Friedrich Merz und was auch Jens
Spahn heute morgen ja auch nicht oft
genug betonen können ist dass es aus
ihrer Sicht ruckelt in der
Bundesregierung ruckelt ich möchte
fragen kann es vielleicht sein dass sie
in der Union vielleicht einfach nicht
mehr wissen wie es sich anfühlt wenn
sich was bewegt in diesem Land es
ruckelt ja vor allen Dingen deswegen
weil so lange Stillstand war wir machen
den Monaten was vorher
nicht ging
und an der Stelle an der Stelle die
Frage zu stellen ist es vielleicht auch
gut dass mal was ruckelt weil neue Wege
auch nach Streit verlangen um diese
neuen Wege überhaupt erst definieren zu
können die man hier beschreiten will
und dann auch bei Friedrich Merz und
Jens Spahn ist ja auch der Vorwurf nicht
weit das würde es wäre hier
führungsversagen der Bundesregierung
ganz ehrlicherweise muss ich sagen es
gibt gerade genug Beispiele auch in
Europa für echtes führungsversagen wenn
wir nach Großbritannien schauen 44 Tage
von List fast die haben gezeigt was
wirklich an verheerenden Folgen da als
wenn echtes führungsversagen Haushalts-
und finanzpolitische Verwerfungen
produziert was die DFB gerade in Katar
abliefert auch echtes führungsversagen
und wenn ich ganz kurz noch mal auf die
CDU schauen will die CDU als mit Abstand
größte konservative Parteien in diesem
Land und das sage ich auch als jemand
der aus Sachsen kommt eine der
vornehmsten Aufgaben der größten
konservativen Partei gerade auch als
Lehrer aus den 20 Jahrhundert ist
führungs zu zeigen Führung die Friedrich
Merz auch bei Amsterdam angekündigt hat
als Partei dafür zu sorgen dass die
Brandmauer gegen Rechts auch in diesen
Krisenzeiten stehen bleibt und dass sie
gehegt und gepflegt wird und jeder ist
der Auftritt sofort zugespachtelt wird
und dann führungsversagen zu reden wenn
man in der eigenen cdu/csu es nicht
schaffen ostdeutsche CDU lass ich im
bundesdeutschen Fernsehen hinstellen und
Friedrich Merz persönlich mit dem
Schicksal von Marie Antoinette drohen
wenn er weiter auf dieser Brandmauer
besteht dann erwarte ich auch von
Friedrich Merz als Parteivorsitzende
dass an der Stelle die Kapitänsbinde
nicht so sträflich abstreift wie das der
DFB tut dass er nicht einfach nur den
Mund hält sondern dass er den Mund
aufmacht wenn es unangenehm wird das ist
seine Aufgabe in diesen Zeiten für den
Erhalt der Demokratie weil ich will in
20 und in 30 Jahren
apropos Kapitänsbinde man hat jetzt
gestern auf Twitter gelesen die soll
jetzt schon ins Haus der Geschichte
überführt werden ehrlich gesagt glaube
ich nicht dass ich in 20 oder 30 Jahren
wenn wir diese Demokratie erfolgreich
durch die Krise gebracht haben das wird
uns dann Armbinden aus Polyester
anschauen wollen im Haus der Demokratie
sondern die Modernisierungsprojekte die
auch in diesem Haushalt schon angelegt
sind die automatisierte digitale
Kupplung die den Eisenbahngüterverkehr
revolutionieren wird vielleicht auch der
erste mRNA Impfstoff gegen Krebs der in
Deutschland hergestellt wird das sind
glaube ich die Sachen die wir im Haus
der Geschichte in 30 und 40 Jahren sehen
wollen und meine Damen und Herren Krisen
sind Katalysatoren für Modernisierung
und Krisen sind Katalyse Katalysatoren
dafür dass wir unglaublich schnelle
Schritte vorwärts machen in dieser
Gesellschaft und ganz ehrlich dieser
Bundeshaushalt ist Teil dieser
katalysatorischen Wirkung und ich freue
mich auf die vielen Modernisierungen die
wir auch im nächsten Jahr schon werden
beobachten können vielen herzlichen Dank
Schlussrunde im Deutschen Bundestag zum